good morning everyone and welcome to the
house committee on Health and Human
Services and elderly Affairs we have
several Senate bills uh to uh we will be
engaging in public hearing uh with today
uh but before that I'd like to ask you
to please join me in the Pledge of
Allegiance
I pledge allegiance to the fire in the
United States of America and to the
Republic for which it stands our nation
under God individuals with liberty and
justice
thank you everyone and again welcome
yes uh
no
okay uh the first bill for our
consideration this morning is a Senate
Bill 32 I want to keep saying house
bills but Senate bills uh 32 and uh I'd
like to recognize the prime sponsor
Senator Rosenwald thank you thank you
very much Mr chairman it's a pleasure to
be here for the record I'm Cindy
Rosenwald and I represent Senate
District 13 in Nashua and as chair of
the opioid abatement advisory committee
commission I'm pleased to introduce
Senate bill 32. this bill makes changes
to the operation of the opioid abatement
fund originally created in 2020 to
manage the distribution of settlement
funds for opioid litigation that will be
coming into the state for the next 18
years or so
in total we expect over that period New
Hampshire will receive more than 300
million dollars to mitigate the harms of
the opioid epidemic
so when we receive a check 15 percent of
that money goes out immediately to the
23 litigating
subdivisions and the balance goes into
the opioid abatement fund
the opioid agreement advisory commission
has the responsibility and authority to
Grant these monies for a variety of
purposes laid out in statute
there are 22 members on the commission
representing subject matter experts HHS
Corrections Department of Justice the
governor's Commission on Alcohol and
Other Drugs and County and Municipal
governments
we held our first round of Grant
applications last fall for 6.6 million
dollars
the contracts for award grantees are
being finalized
to go before the executive Council
hopefully next month
since that first round more money has
come into the fund and we have just
agreed to issue an RFP that make five
million dollars for reimbursement of
medications for substance use disorder
available
this bill comes out of our experience in
soliciting and awarding grants over the
past year and it does several things
first it establishes a requirement that
we give out grants at least once a year
when there is at least five million
dollars in the fund we will collaborate
with HHS on the number of times we will
do this in any given year and I should
also note that there's really likely to
be at least five million dollars in the
fund every year for the next 18 years
because of the way the settlements are
structured
but how however there is currently no
statutory language about how often we
give out grants or how much money
we would need to give out
second it clarifies and makes a couple
of additions to eligibility categories
for Grants these are recommendations
from the subject matter experts it also
expands the reimbursement for
medications for substance use disorder
treatments to recognize that naloxone is
not the only FDA approved product and
finally it updates language to reflect
best practices in the field and fixes a
couple of typos in this statute I'd be
happy to answer questions but both the
doj is here and HHS is here and they
probably are better subject matter
experts than I am okay do you want
you're willing to answer questions yes I
am sure are there any questions from
committee members
thank you Mr chairman and you may choose
to defer this if you prefer I was just
wondering about the 15 that we're not
talking about and you said that goes to
litigating subdivisions and I just
wondered as a matter of curiosity who
those were
um Mr buffetti from the doj can reel
them off a memory but it's a range of I
know Nash was one
um I think Laconia maybe some counties
he knows thank you very much
thank you anyone else any other
questions from committee members
I'm seeing none thank you thank you
senator
okay also signed up to speak is James
good morning Mr chairman members of the
committee my name is James buffetti I am
the deputy Attorney General
and I have been the point person at doj
for its opioid litigation since 2015.
I'm also a member of the um the opioid
abatement commission that Senator
Rosenwald just mentioned uh so we we
come in support of this legislation
these are recommendations made by the
commission that would clarify and
streamline
um some of the processes the object
being trying to get this money out as
quickly as we can as it comes in so that
we can use it in our communities to help
Abate the opioid crisis I'm happy to
answer any questions about the
settlements of the various settlements
the amounts that are coming in there was
a question from representative Weber
about which communities are receiving
the
um the 15
and I can say that um those those
communities are the ones that filed
their own lawsuits and they include all
10 counties
plus
Berlin Claremont Concord Derry Dover
Franklin Keen Laconia Londonderry
Manchester Nashua
and Rochester
um and I can tell you that with the
money that's already come in that's
6.68 million dollars has already been
distributed to those 23 subdivisions
under New Hampshire uh the the New
Hampshire statute uh we anticipate I
think currently we have in the opioid uh
trust fund we have approximately 38
million dollars
most of that money came from a one-time
settlement that the Attorney General
reached with Johnson and Johnson to
settle our opioid lawsuit with them we
went on our own we didn't join the
national settlement and uh New Hampshire
received a one-time payment of 31
million dollars last fall from J J to
settle their opioid claims in New
Hampshire so all of that money is in
there but as Senator Rosenwald said
these are structured settlements they're
they're all individual settlements with
all individual terms some of a result of
bankruptcy proceedings that are yet to
be resolved some have been resolved and
that there will be periodic payments
coming in over the next 17 to 18 years
my estimate is that
at the end of the day that New Hampshire
will receive about 310 million dollars
over 18 years so this commission will be
functioning for a long time uh and will
be
um uh trying to figure out the best most
effective ways of using the money to
help address the opioid crisis by law
and by bankruptcy settlement all of the
monies have to be used for opioid
abatement purposes things like treatment
transportation to treatment housing for
people coming out of treatment drug
court
for naloxone for medication assisted
treatment which is the most effective
way of treating people with an opioid
addiction
so I'm happy to answer any questions
that you have about the settlements and
uh and any other questions that you may
have for me
thank you uh questions uh representative
Merchant
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
the question
in regards to the funds being used for
treatment abatement if you will is there
any focus on trying to build programs to
prevent the use of opiates in the first
place yes well there is so as the
senator said the statute contains 15 or
so permitted uses of the opioid money so
the grant the the grant applications
have to conform with one or more of
those uses there is a there is a An
approved use for prevention work
especially in schools and so that would
now be dependent upon uh schools and
other organizations who would make
proposals to do exactly that and if they
did then that would be uh considered by
the by the commission we make
recommendations so the governor and
executive Council for the actual funding
decisions
follow-up follow-up is the
restriction
limited to schools or could it be used
for something to do with adults because
part of from going with this is we have
a house bill 66. and party it is trying
design if we if you would the ability to
use none
pharmacological Therapies in order to
not utilize as much an opiates to begin
with
and part of that is trying to figure out
how we can fund that kind of initiative
because if we can keep people from using
opiates in the first place
do we minimize the issue we're dealing
with to be today
I think that they could clearly be a way
if if an organization a non-profit or a
a state agency or a local government had
a proposal I think that they could they
could certainly fit it into the the
approved uses that are in the statute
thank you
seeing no other questions thank you
also signed up to speak is uh Jake Barry
good morning Mr chair honorable members
of the committee my name is Jake Berry
I'm the vice president of the vice
president of policy of new Futures as
many of you know new Futures is a
nonpartisan non-profit Health policy and
advocacy organization we've been working
for nearly 25 years to address alcohol
and substance use issues in our state I
don't want to repeat too much of what's
been said this morning but I do want to
emphasize new future strong support for
this bill specifically we support the
provisions that clarify that the opioid
debate and trust fund can be used to
support harm reduction programs as well
as the language that requires the trust
funds advisory commission to work in
coordination with the governor's
Commission on Alcohol and Other Drugs
and other relevant State plans
first and foremost harm reduction as I'm
sure you all know is an approach that
emphasizes engaging directly with people
who use drugs to prevent overdose and
connect individuals to treatment it's
increasingly recognized as a critical
part of the Continuum of substance use
disorder services this proposal to add
harm reduction reference in the bill as
primary secondary and tertiary
prevention and program Services is a
natural extension of the work of the
trust fund and would build on the
legislature's work from last year adding
prevention programming in SB 275.
incorporating the harm reduction would
close the loop and would ensure support
ensure the full Continuum of sud
Services can be funded through the trust
fund
in addition we believe that empowering
the fund to work in coordination with
the governor's commission and in
alignment with other state plans will
enhance the coordination of these bodies
and ensure a comprehensive funding plan
for substance misuse programs throughout
our state uh with that we ask you to
support this bill and I'm happy to take
questions thank you thank you questions
from committee members
representative Palazzo
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question in in your experience
with the uh what's the different success
rate for this programs for people for
substance abuse disorder especially in
um specifically around how production
harm reduction programs uh no like if
somebody has a substance you uh you use
disorder with opioids like what's the
success relatives that person uh
uh participates in one of those programs
how many of them stop abusing opioids
sure sure I can tell you so I I don't
have the data in front of me but you
know there are many different parts of
the Continuum of services for some
substance use tradition each one of them
comes with different different data and
different success rates as you say
um you know certainly we see harm
reduction as addressed in the provisions
of this bill as you know a really
important piece to connect with people
who aren't ready to fully enter the tree
in the treatment system yet right you
know people who for whatever reason are
still determined or still experiencing
substance use disorder and and so in
active use of of substances um you know
provide adding them with the you know
with clean needles clean equipment
really prevents fatal overdoses uh you
know it prevents deaths uh it also is an
incredible opportunity to connect people
with information about treatment
programs for when they are ready to
enter treatment protocols so
um you know I I can get you more
hardened data but it is uh you know here
in New Hampshire and all across the
country these kind of harm reduction
programs are are just seen as a critical
entryway to getting people into the
substance use treatment continual
sure thank you other questions
representative Merchant thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking the questions
bear on the back of your letter that you
handed out there's a diagram is that
coming from where
uh it's reference you know I do
apologize I'm here on behalf of a
colleague who drafted and crafted that
uh that that testimony uh so I I don't
know I'm happy to follow up on that and
get you to get you the source for it
saying no other questions okay thank you
also signed up to speak is Jenny O
Higgins from the Department of Health
foreign
good morning thank you so much for
having me and I'm Daniel Higgins I'm the
legislative liaison for Behavioral
Health for DHHS so the department has
um worked closely with the commission on
all of this work and is in support of
all of the language changes really
wanted to just be here today because we
did submit a fiscal note on this bill
but because the actual language changes
throughout the bill are not what are not
what makes the need for positions in the
department that language was removed in
the fiscal note so I just wanted to make
sure to talk a little bit about the
capacity for the Department to make sure
to move the opioid abatement funds
quickly and monitor and oversee them
um really well and so that that's one
piece that we just wanted to make sure
to talk about today so all of the
language pieces everyone else has
already spoken to they are best practice
and Progressive and help us to
destigmatize these issues they also make
sure that we're serving people
appropriately with evidence-based
practice says so in full support of all
the language changes we also worked
closely on around making sure to
collaborate with the department so we
can get those solicitations out
um so really what we had put in our
initial fiscal note was around having
three positions one that is currently
funded with these opioid abatement funds
today that was approved by the
commission August 1st 2022 but we are
looking to codify that position so that
they can continue to monitor all of
these solicitations get the procurements
out in a timely manner and get them to
contract and additionally we were
looking to have a part a part-time
auditor and an accountant to
specifically work on this fund and those
positions are all mirrored after other
programs that we have of a similar size
So based on the amount of funding and
how we move that funding through the
department
thank you thank you taking questions sir
yes any question our representative
Shapiro
thank you Mr chairman and thanks for
taking this question this may be
tangential to this bill but having you
know hearing about the FDA approval for
Max alone over
over the counter
um and seeing that this bill talks about
opioid reversal agents and the
reimbursement for them
um
is it within your purview to know how
those will interact with each other will
the state be reimbursing
less people will more people be being
have having to be paid pay for these
counter approval has happened but it's
not in it has not had implementation so
we don't know all of the details of how
that will roll out at this point I see
it as additional potential access but if
people don't have health insurance
coverage and go to get that
over-the-counter they may or go to pay
for these things they may not be able to
afford them so making sure that we
continue to have
um any opioid reversal agents available
through Statewide funding at this point
our federal grants still support the
purchase and distribution of naloxone
and we would continue to do that from
the safe perspective and the
over-the-counter would just add an
additional access for potentially for
people
thank you sure representative Weber
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question I want to back up a
little bit because you were talking
about the fiscal note and I'm
apologizing because I've lost all
control over my email uh have we had the
fiscal note or did you say you withdrawn
the fiscal note or
um I didn't quite understand I it sounds
to me like you've got one funded
position that you are confirming in this
legislation and then you're asking for
the auditor and part-time yes thank you
very much and could you just point me to
where that is and uh point me to whether
you have a fiscal note or have sent the
fiscal note or do it what what's
happening with the fiscal note thank you
I need to just take a breath and slow
down I think too because I'm coming in a
little bit few minutes late from
something else so need to wrap my brain
around this and better explain myself so
thank you for helping me clarify that so
we submitted a fiscal note work she does
the department the legislative budget
assistant
said that the positions are not due to
the changes made in this legislation and
so the positions actually would have
been needed in the legislation when it
passed in 2020 however we didn't we
hadn't received in money at that time
when we passed this initial piece and we
were working to build up the commission
to get to a place where it was ready to
do a procurement now that we're starting
to move funding and we're realizing the
amount of funding that will flow through
the department we want to make sure we
can move that at a steady Pace that we
can put these procurements out quickly
that we can get the contracts into place
and that we can monitor and oversee the
contracts
um in an efficient way and so for those
reasons we've recognized the need for
the positions the commission also
recognized that need for a position and
at this time has funded one project
manager for the for abatement
and additionally we're looking to add an
auditor and finance person to continue
to move the contracts and we based those
positions on other similar size grants
like State opioid response and our block
grants
sure follow up
okay so I got that last bit the first
time around so am I correct that what
you're saying is we're just not thinking
about those positions in the context of
this legislation this legislation is
what it is and you will seek those
positions elsewhere
so I think we could do we have several
potential ways forward one is that the
commission has already
funded one of the positions right so we
could go to the commission and ask for
the funding for the three positions in
that way
um it could be potentially codified the
position could be codified in this piece
of legislation or through hb2 right so I
think those are sort of three Pathways
so all I'm really trying to nail down is
whether there is or is not a fiscal note
whether there is going to be or is not
going to be a fiscal note and maybe the
question is for Mr chairman whether this
is going to finance after it finishes
with us
I don't believe this is an early Bill
okay I don't believe it is okay well and
and if if the fiscal note is being
divided off from this it wouldn't be so
um uh I think I think I've clarified the
situation enough for my purposes given
that we're the policy committee anyway
thank you Mr chairman thank you thank
you for taking thank you other questions
from committee members I representative
I'm thinking Mr chairman and think of
what they can my question basically the
same question you mentioned
evidence-based approach and I wonder
when we are talking about three-month of
uh substance use just all this like what
percentage of people in different
programs stop using opioids as a result
of participating in those programs that
are funded through this method
so at this time the first round of
funding has just gone out and so there
isn't we don't have the actual the
tracking of what this funding direct
outcomes to that because this is the
very first time we've done a procurement
with this funding
but are you asking about how often
like when you choose the best programs
like what outcome you expect to expect
like the 10 percent stop by using
opioids or what the success rate that uh
currently is acceptable
ful other chronic illnesses
diabetes and decent is where there are
stunned you know genetics environmental
factors and the individual and those
risk factors so tends to but depending
on the treatment and the individual
tends to be
um in the 30 to 50 percent range of
depending on how you define success and
representative Weber I was just advised
by represent by Ms Dyer it is an early
bill this is going to go to finance Echo
so so we can push all of that off
other questions from committee members
I'm seeing none okay thank you very much
thank you
I have no one else signed up to testify
on Senate Bill 32 does anyone else wish
to testify
okay I'm going to close the public
hearing on Senate Bill 32 we have just a
couple minutes before we will begin the
public hearing on Senate Bill 34 and we
are awaiting the arrival of its prime
sponsor I don't believe Senator gray is
here yet so
to Mike how you doing
very good which one is that one okay
um
thank you
oh are you you're not introducing it
though I mean
no
I'll need a legislator to do that we'll
if you don't mind yeah we'll give them a
couple minutes and then we'll I'm sure
time and begin the public hearing on
Senate Bill 34 and I'll recognize the
prime sponsor Senator gray good morning
uh thank you Mr chair this is uh my name
is James Gray I represent Senate
District Six which starts up in the
gilmington Alton area and goes down
Route 11 to Rochester
uh I'm gonna make this uh short and
sweet I know that the department
provided me a whole bunch of bullet
points but I'm going to let them speak
to it
um many of the bills that that we deal
with uh and especially the uh
you know if you if you look at
percentage-wise we fix little things
that we missed you know when we did the
Bills in the first place and again this
bill does a lot of that when we shifted
the program uh from oplc Back to the
department uh there is a few things that
we need to clean up and certainly the
department is here to talk about those
and because my voice is what it is I'm
going to stop there unless there's any
questions from the you individuals
any questions with Senator Gray
I'm seeing none thank you Senator thank
you
also signed up to speak with Michael
Holt from the Department of Health and
foreign
members of the committee
my name is Michael Holt
um
I'm a section chief who oversees the
prescription drug monitoring program for
the division of Public Health Services
this is
um
regarding the uh the pdmp
so the background of this bill is that
on July 1st 2021 uh
the pdmp was transferred from the office
of professional licensure and
certification to the Department of
Health and Human Services via house bill
2. and since that time we've identified
some remedial needs for some remedial
legislation so this bill is a cleanup
bill with a number of technical fixes
that were overlooked in the transfer
from H from oplc to HHS
senatal 34 proposes the following it
replaces instances of program
administrator with commissioner to
reflect the appropriate entity for
regulatory enforcement consistent with
other programs run by an executive
branch agency it corrects the name of
the governor's Commission on Alcohol and
Other Drugs with uh with regard to a uh
The pdmp Advisory Council membership
it transfers two provisions of law back
to oplc which were transferred to DHHS
and error one having to do with the
definition of chronic pain
and the other having to do with uh
prescriber competency requirements uh
those are more appropriate to uh to have
remained with oplc oplc is the support
of those changes
I don't believe they're here to testify
but they send their regards and lastly
and perhaps most importantly what the
bill does it allows the department to
release aggregate de-identified pdmp
data by County
when the when the program was
transferred
um via House Bill 2 a provision was
added that added a very strict
confidentiality requirement a specific
site to a specific HIPAA provision would
known as The Safe Harbor standard and
what that requires is that that requires
that
uh data cannot be released except on a
Statewide level with one exception
we are allowed to release data based on
zip code the first three digits of a zip
code so what you see in the handout um
is a is a is a visual of that zip three
mapping over the uh over the state and
you can see that it's not aligned with
any county lines
um and so the request here is to allow
us to uh allow the department to release
de-identified aggregate data by County
like the pdmp has historically done and
um that so that that data can be used
um effectively with other county level
data
um so that's the uh that's the bill it's
a it's remedial
um I understand that uh um
representative Merchant may have an
amendment to this bill
um regarding the first point
um the program administrator to
commissioner we've worked
collaboratively collaboratively with
representative Merchant um and I believe
the language he has uh in his back
pocket is agreeable to us uh as well
um but I'm happy to take any any
questions uh regarding the the so the
legislation instead of kind of like a
housekeeping bill is I would absolutely
consider this a housekeeping Bill
oh oh I'm sorry
I didn't know that was a laden term I
sorry representative Weber and my
apologies I'm behaving badly here it's
just we have had in the past many
housekeeping bills which turned out to
make significant programmatic changes so
it's always a little bit of a red flag
for us but
um I just I
I know that my county is sixth from the
top in population uh I assume the cost
is the smallest county do you know what
the population of colossa is is it over
the twenty thousand that it is over the
twenty thousand yes I just I should know
that but thank you um right interest
interestingly if I if I may
um the uh we we do have a zip three
designation that is under 20 000 people
um which which makes releasing zip three
data even uh well impossible because we
we the the allowance is to really zip
three data for
um areas that have under uh more than
twenty thousand so even under this law
you know the current scheme we can't
first a comment and a question
um I wanted to recognize Mr Holt for the
work he's done in the prescription drug
monitoring program we don't always see
III but I think collectively a lot has
been accomplished and this is an example
of that
what I did
work with Mr hold on and also Mr
Williams is where it said program
my concern was
who in the program is going to be the
one to sign a release
because it's too broad what we agreed on
I think is to have designated program
staff so the commissioner can designate
somebody in the staff do work on her
behavior his behalf and not have a sort
of open-ended and that's kind of the
language we have come to I think an
agreement on
thank you other questions
yes representative Murphy thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking the
question Mike it's
um
I'll agree that everything that was
mentioned above seems like a
housekeeping you know update but
um the last bullet is that consistent
with uh Federal HIPAA
um protocol when releasing data by
counties in other states or how does
that work elsewhere is that something
that was missed and we are just catching
up with the federal standard for HIPAA
or not
when
the program was transferred from lplc to
HHS
a provision was added to the law which
required compliance with the Safe Harbor
standard for HIPAA so that was a change
however once it was once we tried to
implement that became clear that uh that
was not something that would work with
all of our data because we can't we need
to release this at least by County data
um so it is a there are multiple levels
of HIPAA standards
um the one in the law is the Safe Harbor
standard this bill still establishes
that Safe Harbor standard but allows for
a carb out with regard to locational
data to allow us to release that by
County so I I would I would say that
it's a bit of a mix of you know a
standard HIPAA standard um and a New
Hampshire version of maintaining that
standard with a carve out
just quick follow-up so it's technically
then a quasi housekeeping type of change
in the bill
okay so thank you you're welcome
see I'm seeing no other questions okay
thank you
I have no one else signed up to testify
on Senate Bill 34 does anyone else wish
to testify
saying no one I am going to close public
hearing on Senate bill 34.
uh and uh the next hearing will be in
about three minutes uh at 10 15 on
huh
foreign
and
um filling in for a senate award is
Daley frenette from the um from the
Senate staff to introduce Senate Bill
good morning chairman McDonald and
members of the committee my name is
Daley frenette and I am the Senate
majority caucus director I'm here today
to introduce Senate Bill 87 on behalf of
Senator Ward
Senate Bill 87 allows certain nurses to
practice in youth camps organize
Recreation and community-sponsored
Recreation settings the intent of the
bill is to allow fewer restrictions on
nurses and other medical personnel that
work in the youth recreation camps in
order to combat the ongoing Healthcare
Workforce shortage in New Hampshire
the amendment to the bill clarified some
of the definitions and standards that
need to be met by those medical
personnel
Senate Bill 87 was unanimously voted off
to pass with Amendment on the consent
calendar by the Senate so thank you for
allowing me to speak today I appreciate
it Senator Ward is in Senate education
right now so I will defer any uh
questions to The Advocates behind me
okay also signed up to speak is Henry
great detail
between the New Hampshire YMCA to
support this as an effort to help the
nurse nurse situations
of Summer Camps
um
okay also signed up to speak is uh
Stephanie castles for New Hampshire
camps
everyone's deferring to you so we'll
um thank you for allowing me to speak
today my name is Stephanie casells I'm a
resident of Tuftonboro New Hampshire in
Carroll County and I'm here representing
New Hampshire campus Association as a
board member and we are in support of
the Bell
I'm a co-director and the medical
director of YMCA Camp bellnap in
Tuftonboro New Hampshire
my Camp serves 1200 kids each summer on
Lake Winnipesaukee I'm also a nurse
practitioner at Dartmouth
hospital in Lebanon New Hampshire and
additionally I serve as an Advisory
Board member for the alliance for Camp
Health which is a National Organization
so
um today
um New Hampshire Camp directors is in
support of the bill camps are vital to
the support of Youth right now New
Hampshire serves 150
000 kids in the summer through summer
camp
um we have over a hundred member camps
um
nurses are really key to the health and
safety of our community in summer camp
and camps are required by DHHS to have
nurses on staff
and so we've worked closely on this bill
with the nurse Association and agreed to
the language in the bill
the bill is a continuation of a policy
and law that has already been in place
for the last several years with the
pandemic Senate bill 277.
um we see this bill allowing camps to
continue to get qualified nurses quickly
um
really you know being a healthcare
professional as well as a camp director
I'm acutely aware of the Staffing
challenges you are all aware of
um you know our
it's hard to get nurses at this point
and and the cost is high and so camps
are particularly challenged because we
are seasonal and we are having to be
more flexible in terms of how we're
bringing nurses in so it might be for a
week or a weekend that we have a nurse
on staff
um and it is really essential that we're
able to get that nurse licensed as quick
as possible
um you know we don't have several months
leading into sometimes bringing those
nurses into camp and this um our hope is
this will help continue
um that previous Senate bill um to allow
to nurses to get licensed quickly
um open to questions thank you oh yes
representative Cushman
thank you this is just a simple question
in the analysis of the bill it it says
nurse practitioners I think it means
practicing nurses yes okay thank you
other questions yes representative Weber
thank you
so if I'm reading the bill right what it
does is it allows retired nurses who
retired in good standing and have kept
up continuing education requirements to
perform these duties and it also allows
not yet qualified nursing students under
certain circumstances to also perform
the duties is that correct correct the
the second part of the question with you
know not yet they're not yet licensed
right so
um the concept is again you can see that
there's a supervision aspect put in
there for them as well and that would be
my follow-up question if I may Mr chair
the follow-up question is it it says
uh I've lost my place here uh directly
supervised while providing Health Care
Services uh does direct supervision
require the supervisor to be on site or
what exactly is contemplated by direct
Supervision in this in this instance
yeah so I think that the employed by
part is I'm not sure I have a good
answer to that I think it definitely
you're correct it does leave
probably someone you know interpretation
um and and the Nurses Association
probably right would have some idea
around what I'll say but then thank you
very much representative Merchant thank
you Mr and also thank you for taking the
question
I understand today
oplc can issue a temporary license for
up to I think it's 100 120 days
if they can do that today then why do we
need this bill
so right now the Senate Bill 277 is in
place till June 30th and then that goes
away and they won't be issuing
um unless so I'm looking at the RSA 310a
and it talks about issuing temporary
licenses okay
I'm not sure
um I'm totally aware of
um I do know prior is that something
um that was between in the last four
years it was authorized according to
this on July 1st became Act of the 2021.
okay so I'm not saying not to do this
but yeah one of the other concerns that
I have Mr chair sure is I understand
about nursing students I want to involve
and representative Weber's question
as a student is a supervision of it
um I'm concerned about having a student
who hasn't passed their exams yet and
what kind of supervision they're going
to have because
they probably leave all the people on
this list of people who can do this need
more supervision and I think having
somebody remotely supervising them
I find problematic if they're not
literally on site
other questions yes representative
Murphy my name is Chairman and thank you
for taking the question
um I'm not sure what division or
Department you practice in a DH right
now but my question would be is there a
particular expertise that's required for
a camp nurse
um so if you're a Rheumatology nurse
practitioner you may not be familiar
with bug bites or you know allergic
reactions or broken bones I mean there's
a spectrum of the kids pathology that
may come in and I wasn't sure if the
camp nurse has any I wouldn't say
specialized but any differential
training that's required to get into the
camps so there isn't specific
um training that is required
um in terms of the hiring process you
know you would
cancer hiring people who are qualified
candidates right so I think um those
people hiring are are aware of what's
you know needed in in the camp setting
um as well so part of this is right you
know there's only so much access to a
certain number of nurses and especially
you know
um not having all the
um the states in a compact licensing
licensing situation so nurses also have
what we call the compact license where
you can go over States but it doesn't
exist for all of our surrounding states
thank you
um being very familiar with the camps in
New Hampshire obviously
um is there a a staff to camper ratio
that you have to maintain uh in these
camps
um so for instance you may have a
contestant which has I don't know how
many X number but then you have your
Camp which has a large number perhaps on
webasaki is there a ratio that you have
to maintain there's there's a minimum
number of nurses that need to be on site
as far as licensing per camper yeah
president okay thank you
so you know other questions okay thank
I have no other cards from people who
have signed up does anyone else wish to
testify on Senate Bill 87
.
and turn this off either so thank you
um so just going back I I we we're all a
little fuzzy on the um direct
Supervision in this uh bill so
um I'm also just wondering in on page
to online 27
um where it says that the student has to
be employed by or providing health care
services at the direction of a licensed
Health Care Facility or licensed health
care provider does that mean
um that the camp has someone above them
okay so correct so camps are are
required to have some sort of
someone who is putting
um orders in place so many camps have a
relationship with a hospital or facility
if not a medical director
thank you
that helps thank you
yes uh representative Merchant following
up on uh representative cushman's
question
I haven't been on the Board of Pharmacy
and the award directly supervised became
somewhat of a concern
because it was being supervised
through technology not because the
person was actually on site and the
board had a concern because if you're
remotely available to somebody and
something happens you're not there
physically to deal with the problem
would you be amendable to putting down
the individual's correct is directly
supervised by an on-site
so somebody's actually physically on
site
versus it being interpreted be
through a um
yeah I
um I I would obviously have to speak to
the organization I think we would
discuss that I think we we definitely
discussed though what is directly
supervised and how that could look I
think the intent for many of these
nursing students would be in
in camps where we have several nurses
right at once so your question around
you know some of our camps have you know
four nurses at a time and some have one
so the one nurse might you know again
not be is is hopefully not the intent
yes representative Shapiro
thank you Mr chairman and thanks for
taking this question
um since it seems to me that that
um these were previously licensed nurses
but that will be given a license
um a temporary license once they're
hired by
um and then we'll be under the
jurisdiction of the licensing board for
nurses yeah is there any
is there any issue with these licenses
being
um
provided quickly enough to actually
um make people available for the the
camping season well so that actually I
think is the is the issue the the whole
intents of this is
is to help move those along as quickly
as possible because right now
um
or pre I would say pre-pandemic we would
be four months you need to four months
of having to submit for a nursing
license
I think we probably get a skewed view
but we hear a lot of you know the
complaints about
um you know how long these things take
we don't ever hear or if they happen
efficiently
um so
um I was just wondering if that would be
an issue yeah and I think that that is
the I would say the pre-pandemic before
we had this this language similarly in
place for the Senate bill and again I
don't know the inner workings of the
licensing office but it's been
way better which is why at this point
you know the camping industry said wait
a minute like if we could continue doing
this this would be great right because
it has allowed us to not have that
headache of like oh my gosh our nurse is
trying to get licensed four months ago
and we're about to start camp and I
can't we don't have a licensed verse so
this would improve that yeah thank you
representative Weber did you have a
question
business
okay sorry I didn't mean to skip over
you there
um any other questions
okay I think we're I think we're done
again thank you very much
and again does anyone else want to
testify on Senate Bill 87 I have no one
else signed up
if not then I am going to close the
public hearing on Senate Bill 87 we're
being very efficient so far today
um and the next hearing is not scheduled
until 10 45 so we'll be in recess for 15
minutes at which time we will reconvene
and hear testimony in Senate Bill 171.
thank you
foreign
and open the public hearing on Senate
Bill 171 and recognize the prime sponsor
good morning Mr chair and members of the
committee offer the record I'm Denise
rashardi from uh District 9. I represent
uh 13 towns in Bedford where I live and
then South and West upwards
I'm here to introduce Senate Bill 171
which is relative to the definition of
Youth recreational programs of which I
am the prime sponsor
Senate Bill 171 makes a very small
change that will have a significant
impact on our child care in the state of
New Hampshire the legislation in front
of you allows recreational programs such
as those chartered by the Boys and Girls
Clubs Of America
YMCAs and ywcas who offer before and
after school care programs to be able to
serve our school-aged children
in the early 1990s the legislature
adopted a child care licensing exemption
for recreational programs who served
children six years of age or older
uniquely designed to accommodate the
child care needs of working parents
while recognizing the enhanced safety
protocol
and staff training requirements of these
National organizations and its enactment
the threshold age of six years was
considered appropriate in light of the
expected age of children who needed
supervision before and after school
however since that time the state has
allowed communities to enact full-day
kindergarten programs that enroll
school-aged children who may be younger
than six years as a result of the
inconsistency in these two age limits
the Boys and Girls Clubs and their
fellow recreational programs are not
able to accept some of the children of
families that the recreational program
exemption was designed to benefit even
though the characteristics of the need
and the program offered and
qualifications of the provider are
essentially identical
as you all have heard and seen
anecdotally the need for additional
capacity in our child care and before
and after school space is not it's at an
all-time high we believe that this
meaningful change will give parents and
caregivers another source of quality
programming that will allow them to
maintain employment and stay in the
workforce today you will hear testimony
from providers who think that this is
common sense enhancement to our statute
and from families who would benefit from
the change it's for these reasons that I
ask you to find Senate Bill 171
ought to pass
thank you thank you you're taking
questions senator
I mean some questions but I do have the
experts behind me if I can't do a good
job for you we'll have them come up any
questions for Senator rashardi
it's representative Weber
I just had one what are we contemplating
by the term school age which is the nub
of this bill are we talking kindergarten
on or if there are
I mean
I just I just wonder if we could have a
more precise statement about what we're
talking about there this would allow
five-year-olds versus
to be six years old
um and we did meet in the summer with uh
Doreen Shockley from the Department of
Health and Human Services who was very
supportive of this bill and actually
loved the idea of bringing it forward
and
well I I'm wondering I'm very supportive
of the intent my concern is the actual
language so uh would you have an
objection if we changed it to say
five-year-olds so that we know what
we're talking about or then maybe I
should hold that for other people I
think you should if you don't mind me my
suggestion of waiting to hear all the
testimony okay see if you don't get an
answer that satisfies you better would
that be okay yep sure thank you very
much and thank you for the answer of
course
okay I'm saying done thank you very much
also signed up to speak is Diane
Fitzpatrick from the Boys and Girls Club
good morning chairman
could you put the microphone on please
good morning uh chairman and members of
the committee I am Diane Fitzpatrick uh
the CEO of Manchester Boys and Girls
Club and I'm here today to provide a
testimony for support of sb171
legislation our cloud has approached
Senator Richard IV we thank her for all
her support with this
we strive daily to provide a culture
that welcomes all and gives kids from
every background a sense of belonging
there are no barriers of membership or
No Limits our kids can't achieve
the Boys and Girls Club of Manchester
was established in 1907. we continue to
revolve our programs to meet the needs
of our community
our modding program serves over 200
children we transport them to schools
our afternoon programs serve over 400
kids and that includes Transportation
our programs are more than just a
recreational program we provide
breakfast snack dinners for our children
also we provide free food Fridays for
families that need access to food our
afternoon programs include academic
support steam activities Performing Arts
in the gym activities the senator has
stated that youth recreational statute
was established in the 1990s legislators
recognize the economy of programs
offered by the Boys and Girls Club the
YMCAs Girls Inc incorporated the robust
child safety standards that are required
by our national parent organizations
provide such safety and support for our
children we serve
when the law was considered most
children entering school age of six
entering first grade since then
communities and families are embracing
full day kindergarten and the children's
age is of five
with increase before and after school
care that we see firsthand that sb171
makes a critical change to the statute
that will allow us to serve our families
better not only this kind of current
statue makes a child feel excluded when
their siblings are currently enrolled
our program it prohibits them from
attending
but also requires families to scramble
for alternative child care
recreational programs are critical
component that allows families to work
as well as enriching activities for our
kids
New Hampshire residents need help
finding essential Child Care High
as we move forward away from covid-19
and a return to normalcy for both
parents and their careers and children
with their peers is critical according
to the most recent data that was
provided by after school Alliance for
every one child
in an after-school program in our state
there are two on a waiting list
well this is not a silver bullet we
believe that SB 717 will be another tool
of helping New Hampshire
effectively chip away to the child care
accessibility issue I want to thank you
for your consideration consideration and
respectfully asking to miss Bill ought
to be passed I'd be happy to answer any
questions as well as I have letters from
parents that support this bill
thank you representative Weber
thank you Mr chairman I've now
formulated better my question to the
senator
what my concern is is
if we have different districts that have
different offerings
and once again this is a child care bill
that came from to us for reasons that I
don't understand because I don't have
expertise in this area but if we have
different
districts that are offering different
schooling programs at different ages
do we want to tie the language of this
bill to school age which might vary from
District to District or do we want to
have it age specific and that's a
question that I'm asking because my town
for example offered full day
kindergarten for a decade and a half
before kindergarten it was even required
but other districts very close by did
not offer kindergarten at all and so in
those contexts what is school age I
think it's when I don't know whether
that's even an issue or not so that's
really what I'm asking a question before
we even propose this bill we met with
child care licensing so we are licensed
licensed exempt and what we're asking is
if we can it is school age so in our
community school age would include
five-year-olds going to to our
Manchester School District so I think if
we use that language it would meet the
needs of those districts but the school
the child care licensing is in favor of
this and recognized and that these this
legislation was written in 1990s and we
have continued to evolve our
after-school and child care
did that answer your question
if I may have one follow-up so what I
think you're telling me is you would
prefer the language school age to
anything more specific because it might
float
I would like it to float so I can serve
more families and if if it's
recommendation of the committee that
you'd like to save school year a school
age including kindergarten I think the
key word here is kindergarten well what
I'm trying to drive at is
um if
and I don't even know if there are
schools here who do this in New
Hampshire but if if a school established
a pre-kindergarten program
those children in that District would be
school age
so yep and and
I am all for inclusivity
um
but I'm wondering if they're
if it was contemplated that there would
be no floor
but on the ages just based on differing
needs of kids uh or or whether
I'm just looking at wordsmithing as to
whether what we need is the word school
age or whether we need
five-year-olds and I I guess my other
question would be do some school
districts and I'm hoping somebody behind
you will actually answer this if you
don't know the answer do some school
districts admit kids who have reached
their fifth birthday some some you know
when I went to school there were some
that started if you were going to be
five by December or some you had to be
five by September so it was a different
age for every different school district
and is that the case now and does it
matter and I'm just I'm just trying to
educate myself and then find the right
words
responding sure um I believe and I'm not
this is just from my experience with
education I believe it's September 30th
the child needs to be age five entering
kindergarten it's the language of this
bill could say five-year-olds entering
kindergarten that would clarify
everything any preschool programs if the
Boys and Girls Club of Manchester was to
offer that we would go through child
care licensing and get our program
licensed what we're looking at is
kindergarten five years old and up to
enroll in our morning and after school
programs okay
thank you very much I appreciate that
representative Shapiro
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking this question so I assume that
the way
um statute is currently written that if
someone was five they couldn't go to
your program they'd have to go to a
program that was licensed as a daycare
program yes Okay so what are the
differences in standards in terms of I
I'm not asking you to give me every
difference but but what are the
generally speaking what are the
difference in standards for being
licensed as a daycare versus being
licensed as a recreational program
because we are sending younger we will
be sending younger kids to you and does
through the standards meet their needs
basically
excellent question yes they do and I
think it's ratios so when you think
about ratios my background I was a
kindergarten teacher many moons ago so
we want to make sure our kids have
accurate um ratios for our licensing
we're licensed exempt but we do have to
follow Boys and Girls Club of America's
safety procedures so all our safety
ratios all of those requirements if you
compared our requirements and
competitive child care licensing they're
very similar so you know instead of
going through the State Licensing we're
going through uh Boys and Girls Club
America just as the YMCA but there are
programs if we were to offer a preschool
program I would go and be Child Care
license and the ratios would be smaller
follow up
so that means that the the major
difference in your mind is the ratio of
children to adults so
your program is under Federal under
guidelines that are like Countrywide so
um but there might be programs that
don't have those kinds of guidelines so
the ratios might be
different they could be different I
couldn't speak for all but I when you
really think about the program we're
talking about and our particular
organization but I agree across the
board we're all very in tune to what the
needs are of a five six-year-olds and
making sure we have adequate
um ratios as well as safety
okay thank you you're welcome other
questions
yes
representative American yeah
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking the question is a follow-up on
representative Weber
my concern is when you you we use the
word school-aged and there's no floor to
it um school is to be defined
preschool and so forth et cetera whether
they're going to be included here or not
I am I hearing that you would be
amendable to change the things to write
five years of age at the time to enter
kindergarten at least at that point in
time this definitive amount does two
things one is the fork to it we all
understand and number two it's a
standard across the whole state
absolutely thank you
other questions representative Cushman
uh our our retract my question and I'll
take it offline actually okay
representative okay thank you
other questions
so you know all the questions thank you
also signed up to speak is
uh Doreen Shockley from the Department
good morning committee chair members of
the committee it's a pleasure to sit
here before you today and hopefully
clarify the questions on regarding the
school age program definition
um what we did when we met what seems
like a very long time ago but
um the school age program a school age
program is currently defined in RSA 170
e colon 2 and includes children who are
four years and eight months of age or
older
thank you
is that helpful
thank you Mr chair any more questions
sure you're taking questions okay are
you are you are you including a
testimony or did you have more to say no
I just wanted to no I have no testimony
we were here in support of because we
met but because there were so many
questions regarding the age I thought
I'd clarify that representative King has
a question yes uh just can you uh give
me that that RSA number again certainly
RSA 170 Dash e colon 56.
thank you no I'm sorry that's a
different one
170 Dash e colon 2 just finds school age
program and there we give the age
all right representative Shapiro
thank you Mr chairman I'll ask you the
same question that I just asked
basically which is
um we're bringing younger kids into a
program that currently they have have
programs have to be licensed in a
different way so from your point of view
will the change in standards which were
referred to mostly As ratios of adults
to children
will they be adequate for younger kids
ratios are also described in rules as to
the number of adults per child based on
child ages so those would still need to
be adhered to this is really I don't
want to use the word housekeeping I saw
what that did last time
um but this is really
um we were thankful that they brought it
to our attention that we have two
separate sections of RSA that are in
Conflict so this is right size and
making sure that they're the same okay
so the ratios really are still the same
so the same same age kids thank you very
much you're very welcome representative
Weber
so we am I correcting thinking we would
solve both your needs and my word
smithing Problems by uh simply adding
school age
as defined in 170-e Colon two we would
be certainly amendable to that as okay
and that way we have the direction and
reference to where in the statute it's
defining it absolutely thank you very
much thank you that was all on my other
questions
I'm saying no other questions thank you
I have no one else signed up to testify
on Senate Bill 171 does anyone else wish
to testify
seeing no one else uh I'm going to close
the public hearing on Senate Bill 171
and I am going to open the public
hearing on Senate bill 240.
and recognize the prime sponsor Senator
Apprentice
good morning chair McDonald and members
of
house Health and Human Services for the
record my name is suprentice I'm the
state senator from District Five
covering a large part of Grafton some
communities in Sullivan and one
community in Merrimack County the
beautiful town of New London uh for um
so Dartmouth Health has asked me to
introduce Senate Bill 2 Ford 242 forward
or in really ease of navigation of care
this bill would make a change to RSA 141
H2 the statute that governs conditions
for genetic testing Senate Bill 240
would allow for a health care facility
to disclose genetic testing or lab
results to clinical entities
participating in processes related to
clinical care or research for the
patient for example this would allow a
health facility to work with a clinical
entity to find an Innovative protocol
for a patient that's navigating cancer
treatment or navigating treatment of Lou
Gehrig's disease ALS
I do have um I do have a representative
from Dartmouth Health here that's also
going to be able to testify about the
impact and the change for patients in
this process but I want to say I want to
add in addition to my introductory
comments two pieces
number one is that
well first of all
right now the way the law stands all we
can send to these entities that do
matchmaking with you know like for
cancer patients and for Lou Gehrig's
sees patients do match making for
protocols for their care to you know
hopefully save their life improve their
outcomes all we consent is tissue or
tumor
we are the most restrictive state in
terms of sharing this in New England by
making this change in the law we would
be able to actually send the results
that the results and the analysis that
facilities like Dartmouth Health are
able to do so that is that is really
what this change does that's number one
and number two I want to speak to
consent patients are consented for this
this type of testing however concerns
have been raised they were raised in the
Senate I want to bring up here and work
with this committee on the research part
of this we want we're going to need to
make a change to have make sure that
it's clear that if you are going to if
if the patients are consented if their
information is going to be used for
research purposes
so that um that'd be happy to work with
members of your committee on but uh with
that I'll end my introductory comments
I'll take questions that I can answer
and if not again I do have a
representative from Dartmouth health and
I would be willing to um get back in
touch
okay thank you uh questions any
questions for the senator
I'm saying none okay thank you okay
thank you very much
uh actually I have no one else signed up
to testify does the person from
Dartmouth Health want to testify we do
need a pink card from you
and please put your microphone on thank
you good morning uh for the record my
name is Courtney Tanner I'm the director
of government relations at Dartmouth
health
um so as Senator Apprentice noted
um the statue does drafted currently
restricts the disclosure of genetic
testing results to other clinical
entities including HealthCare Partners
in which we have a formal relationship
with so this restriction unintentionally
prohibits a New Hampshire Healthcare
entity
from matching our cancer patients or
other types of patients with treatment
protocols that involve the use of
genomes to create efficiencies
sometimes entities like Norris cotton
Cancer Center or Dartmouth Health
Medical Center we are using a third
party entity to match patients with the
appropriate treatment protocols
this requirement as as it stands in
current statute is a barrier to
accessing timely care for our patients
in New Hampshire a similarly situated
patient in a different state would not
have to face this hurdle
Senate Bill 240 doesn't change New
Hampshire Health Systems uh consent
requirements or our consent processes
our providers and patients will still
have to engage and informed consent
practices consent to treat consent to
engage in research all Health Care
Systems and clinical entities must
comply with HIPAA thus this bill does
not change that either and we have
robust checks and balances to ensure
that the appropriate research
disclosures are completed and discussed
with the patients however as drafted
today RSA 141 H2 treats genetic testing
differently than it does for other
health than other health information for
example tissue for tissue treatment
Senate Bill 240 removes an
administrative barrier for providers but
more importantly for our patients so
that a provider can work with their care
teams to identify the right treatment
protocols for patients and coordinate
their and coordinate patient care so I
am not a provider I just want to I have
an orange badge I'm not a doctor but I
just wanted to highlight two examples of
where where we see the statue today
creating uh barriers to care
first today the statute doesn't allow as
Senator Apprentice notice noted it
doesn't allow us to work with clinical
Partners to find treatment protocols
based on genetic testing results
um
we an example of this is there's a broca
gene this is a gene that is found in
patients that are at risk for breast
cancer I see Dr Murphy shaking his head
so that's helpful thank you
this knowledge can be used the knowledge
of the of the existence of a Bronco Gene
can be used to to detect risk for breast
cancer but right now our providers can't
communicate the presence of that Gene
without circling back to get additional
consent from the from the patient so we
can't communicate the presence of that
Gene we can't even communicate that
genetic testing was done for this
patient with our clinical partner
when a provider wants to talk about
review case review
um their patients with their research
colleagues they can't even disclose that
genetic testing was done
for example if we have an oncologist
who's working with an ovarian with
ovarian cancer patients we can't even
disclose that the existence of the
broccoli Gene which is my understanding
again I'm not a provider that the
bronchogeneous also can be an indicator
for ovarian cancer risk we can't even
disclose that that Gene exists or that
or that the genetic testing was done and
this is different than tissue treatment
or how we how we treat any other testing
in the Healthcare System
I'm happy to take questions I'm also
happy to take questions back to our care
team who are much more qualified than I
am
but that is that is disclose in my
testimony thank you question says
representative Merchant
thank you Mr chair taking the score to
taking the question
one of the things we I've heard about
has come to my attention is the use of
genetic testing in regards to coverage
for medical care or insurance policy and
so forth my concern is that if you look
at line eight
it goes to either clinical care of the
patient
my concern is someone misinterpreting
that and saying it could go to an
insurance company to for them to decide
upon whether you qualify for
pre-existing conditions and so forth
that that's my concern can you address
that for me please
um that is a question I'm gonna have to
take back to our our team
um you know I would I would just note
that we don't we don't this as Dr as
drafted today as the statue stands today
we don't treat other types of uh testing
results the way in this in such a
restricted way that we do for uh genetic
testing and um those concerns don't
exist for again I've used this example
over and over again but for tissue
testing for example
um so I don't know that that concern
would exist but certainly happy to
Circle back with you on that okay but
would you just when you talk to the team
be sure that those guard rails on this
information so it does not become used
against the patient for qualified for
medical care and that's where I'm trying
to get to with prior authorizations and
so forth puts there I just want to be
sure that that information is in fact
staying within the clinical team
treating the patient not someone who's
paying the bill yeah absolutely I mean
so I I would just note that this all all
health information is HIPAA protected
right so
um we would you have to be mindful of
that too that doesn't change those
practices and policies
thank you representative Weber and then
representative Murphy thank you and
thank you for taking my question I'm now
really bewildered because uh isn't a
patient
allowed
when they sign an informed consent
form
to allow the release of whatever
information they choose to release to
whatever entity they choose to have it
released to already
yes but as interpreted as interpreted
currently RSA 141 treats genetic testing
differently than other types of testing
so it would require an additional
explicit informed consent again or
consent to release information again if
they're need if there needs to be care
collaboration that's the interpretation
of our legal counsel so could I have a
follow-up Mr chair
um
but my question is
um if we're releasing sensitive
information which is representative
Merchant has noticed might be used for
purposes that were not
wanting it to be used for isn't the
remedy simply to ask for the specific
release from the specific patients and
isn't that a good thing rather than a
bad thing and therefore why would we
want to get rid of it I think it is a
good thing I think that the concerns
again because we're treating this type
of information differently I think the
concerns come when it's not moment in
time so when
um say a new treatment protocol comes
out and researchers want to go back and
look at their at the patient at their
patient profile to say okay this new
this new treatment option is available
let me look back to see if I can look
back to see who has the broccoli gene or
other types of genes that are that are
found in genetic testing only that type
of Look Back can't even be done they
can't even they can't even go back and
one follow-up yeah another follow-up but
that's okay but wouldn't the treating
physician
be able to say to their patient oh gee
there's a new protocol
uh may I release your information to see
if you're you're appropriate for that
protocol I'm I'm having a hard time
understanding why that's such a problem
that would be ideal representative Weber
the issue is that a treating physician
and a researcher they're not even able
to communicate that
um the treating Physician's not even
able to communicate that that genetic
testing happened for that patient with
the researcher so there is this gray
wall or barrier that exists right now
representative Murphy thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking the
question uh so I just want to be clear
this would allow
uh providers say a DH to refer patients
to other clinical institutions say that
have different protocols and different
treatments that they're doing that it's
not done locally is that correct
referrals and also allow us to
communicate with our third party
entities to help us find the appropriate
protocols okay just follow up so it's
not just the third party entities also
the treating excuse me the potential
treating facilities that may have
different expertise and with whom we can
share the the patient's uh clinical
information but also their genetic
testing and Analysis that's correct
that's correct thank you yeah
other questions
okay I'm saying no no more questions
uh and and don't forget the pink card
please
also signed up to speak is Mike wallow
thank you Mr chairman for the record
Mike Rolo American Cancer Society cancer
Action Network
in support
after listening to some of the questions
I may have had to reconsider but I'm not
sure I want to testify but
um we are in support
um I think from the very beginning I
want to just stress how important
patient
um privacy is to our organization
um and how serious we take that
um I think where we are in support
um really comes to where uh
representative Murphy has just opened up
to the conversation where this could
potentially open up access to additional
clinical trial options for patients
um this to us is about access to care
it's acts it's a potentially opening up
access to different treatment options
for patients they may not have other
options
keeping in mind their their privacy is
of the utmost importance to us so if
there are issues that you all need to
work out I will leave that to you
um we're not here to speak to that
our main goal is advancing research and
advancing options for for patients and
that's why we would be in support of
legislation like this
and with that I think most of the people
behind me probably want to get to the
next bill so I don't want a Believer I
give that impression to you okay us too
so okay probably happy to take
representative person's question of
course thank you Mr thank you no
question would you be willing to propose
some language that could be added to
this bill to ensure we're protecting the
privacy of the patient from undue harm
because the information was used in a
would you be willing to help us with
grafting language for the bill to ensure
we Safeguard the information so
therefore the information doesn't fall
into of course an entity that's going to
use it detrimental of course I think I I
don't want to speak for our our friends
at Dartmouth but I'm sure they'd be
willing to as well I don't think they
want to see their patients information
go
anywhere else I mean I think that I'm
not from what I'm reading in the bill I
don't think that's going to be an issue
but I I just raise it because it
representative Weber had brought up the
issue of uh of the privacy of the
patient so that's why I bring it up
that's our always the first thing we
think of is the patient's privacy but I
have other questions
so you know the questions thank you
thank you
also signed up to speak is
good morning Mr chairman uh I'm Neil
Kirk former state representative and I
appreciate the opportunity to be here I
look
I live and where and I'm representing
myself I have some material to pass out
Mr chairman I was involved in the
um
rsa141h
which tries to protect
when I read this bill I was a little bit
surprised because
it seems
that everything the sponsors wish to do
can be done currently under law
with the consent of the patient
Apparently after speaking with Miss
Tanner
an attorney for Dartmouth has
strictly interpreted the language in
such a way that even with the patient's
consent
they cannot do what they're proposing to
do
I find that very difficult to believe
but that's the current situation the
problem with their solution to that
is that it broadens
the
use of material for both research and
clinical treatment
and by using the same consent forms as
they're currently using deprives the
individual of knowledge of what is going
to be done with a genetic material so
when he signs the consent form he's not
fully informed about what he's
foreign
if there's some problem with the bill
with the with a statute that makes it
impossible for Dartmouth to do the right
thing by their patients by all means
let's check that but let's make sure
that we are making that we are
protecting your DNA which once it's gone
obviously is totally lost in ways that a
normal reasonable patient who is faced
with 37 forms that he has to sign every
time he goes to the doctor and which he
cannot read not realistically
except if you're like me you spend an
hour in front of the the window reading
all of these forms and Crossing out
things you don't agree with
but I'm one out of one million three
hundred forty thousand people
most people don't have time to do this
and it's up to the legislature to act in
ways that protect those privacy rights I
will try to work with Dartmouth to come
up with some sort of an amendment that
satisfies their need and also protects
the genetic privacy of individuals the
handout that I sent you was a letter
that I had written to Dr Morrow who
testified in the Senate asking him the
same kinds of questions that I've raised
with you
uh I did not hear back from him I just
had an opportunity today to speak with
Miss Tanner
um she seemed amenable to working out
some other language and will proceed to
do that so Mr chairman I hope the
committee will not act on this bill
until you've had an opportunity to see
what Miss Tanner and I can come up with
thank you thank you Mr chairman I'd be
pleased to answer any questions if
members have them any questions for
representative Kirk seeing none thank
you thank you and
[Music]
also signed up to speak as Courtney
okay oh this is the card that you owed
us I'm sorry okay
all right I have no one else signed up
to speak for Senate bill 240. I'm almost
afraid to ask is there anyone else who
wants to sign to speak on Senate bill
240. saying Nona I am going to close the
public hearing on Senate bill 240.
and open the long anticipated public
hearing on Senate Bill 263 and welcome
Senator Jeb Bradley the prime sponsor
good morning
how are you Mr chair members of the
committee
so thank you again Mr chair pleasure to
be here Jeb Bradley representing Senate
District
3. thank you for the opportunity to
testify in support of Senate Bill 263
which passed the Senate coming out of
the Health and Human Services committee
24 to nothing and passed
the Senate 24 to nothing again on a
Voice vote coming out of the finance
committee
this is the third iteration if you will
of
um authorizing Medicaid expansion I've
been pleased to be involved in all three
of the prior pieces of legislation
um this bill is
compared to the previous bills quite
simple it does three things it makes
Medicaid expansion permanent
it reestablishes the oversight
commission that was repealed
at the end of 2022
and it eliminates use of the alcohol
fund to fund the state share and
substitutes if needed liquor fund
Revenue
what Senate pill 263 doesn't do is make
any changes either to session law or RSA
126 a a that are already established
um
okay pieces of law in New Hampshire in
terms of Medicaid expansion the
eligibility stays the same
138 percent of poverty people are
eligible for Medicaid expansion that's
about twenty thousand dollars of income
for a single individual or forty one
thousand four hundred for a family of
four
uses the same managed care criteria that
Focus On Wellness on Mental Health
substance abuse the work requirements
remain in place in State Statute and the
taxpayer protection mechanisms that have
been part of all three iterations of
Medicaid expansion stay in place and
those taxpayer protection
mechanisms are a disallowance of General
funds
to pay for the state's 10 percent share
a wind down of the program if
Federal funding comes in at less than
the 90 percent promise share those
taxpayer protection mechanisms stay in
place
so I think the question I hope that the
question that you will ask that the
Senate asked and arrived at a conclusion
in a bipartisan fashion has Medicaid
expansion worked and I believe the
answer is a resounding yes
if you look at the
um package that I've passed out and I
trust that there's one for every member
of the committee and one extra you'll
see that in the individual Market
insurance rates have dropped in fact for
the targeted population a single 40 year
old we have the lowest individual rates
in the country that's a result of
changes that we made in 2018.
the number of people accessing their
Health Care at the emergency room has
dropped that was also one of the goals
of earlier pieces of legislation
uncompensated care has dropped
uncompensated care is a tax if you will
a hidden tax on anybody with private
insurance in the state of New Hampshire
whether it's in the individual Market or
whether it's through their employer
because what happens when hospitals have
to give care which they're required to
do under federal law at the emergency
room or some other setting and there's
no way to be compensated for that it's
rolled into the rates that they
negotiate with insurance providers as a
hidden tax on whether it's an individual
or employers
Medicaid expansion for the individuals
that are part of Medicaid expansion is
not permanent many people have been on
Medicaid expansion for a short period of
time and then as their life situation
changes they're able to leave Medicaid
expansion and qualify for other health
insurance whether it's through an
employer or on the exchange
we actually have the fourth lowest
percentage of people on Medicaid of any
state in the nation according to the
Medicaid expansion as you'll see from
some of the fact sheets provided has
provided enhanced services and access to
people with mental health issues as well
as substance abuse and obviously our
crises our dual crises of Substance
Abuse and Mental Health
it's very important that we maintain
those services
and the cost has proven to be affordable
the federal government has maintained
its 90 percent funding
requirement and the state has been able
to meet its 10 percent share without use
of General funds whether it's liquor
funds the insurance premium tax on
Medicaid policies
the New Hampshire Health Plan assessment
and other smaller sources of revenue
so the question I think that you will
hear today and hopefully you will be
able to answer as the Senate answered
have individuals benefit and I think
you're going to hear a lot of testimony
from a lot of people the Senate heard a
lot of this testimony about how people
were able with Access to Health Care to
change their lives to be able to get
into the workforce and Lead productive
lives you will also see countless
letters and support by various business
organizations that know that a healthy
Workforce is absolutely essential for
the economy of the State of New
Hampshire and if you look at all of the
Chambers of Commerce that support it the
New Hampshire retail association the Bia
I was given a letter by the New
Hampshire Bankers Association this
morning the support among the business
Community
is Broad
the only two issues that came up in
testimony and discussion in front of the
Senate
um
are these two that I
recall
is Medicaid expansion providing an
incentive not to work and I would argue
that the opposite is true which is why
you have so many business groups and
individuals in support of it and
referring back to the Kaiser Family
Foundation
study that shows that we have the fourth
lowest percentage of our residents on
Medicaid
seventy percent of New Hampshire
residents on Medicaid are working that's
higher than the U.S average of 63
percent and only eight percent uh only
eight states have a higher percentage of
Medicaid recipients that are working so
I think in terms of a disincentive
clearly not one
the other issue is the question of
making it permanent and I think that
after nine years with the taxpayer
protection mechanisms we've built into
it the wellness incentives that have
been built into it how it's helped
people how it's helped the business
Community I believe it's time to make it
permanent to allow for the most
cost-effective Contracting with Managed
Care organizations so Mr chair at that
point at this point I'd be more than
happy to try to answer your questions
thank you senator
nice okay no it's representative Cushman
thank you Mr chairman thank you senator
for being here and for taking my
question
um I understand that we have uh you know
we've got these reductions in uninsured
residents and I often hear people kind
of um conflate
um insurance with health and I was just
wondering if there are real world
um demonstrable
um
improvements in the health of granite
Staters as a result of this program well
thank you for the question
representative Cushman I think that you
will hear the same testimony that the
Senate heard from actual individuals
who've benefited significantly and I
think if you look at and hear the
testimony from the New Hampshire
Hospital Association
they will go through the drop in
uncompensated care which as I said
before is a hidden tax the drop in
people showing up at the emergency room
and getting care that don't have
insurance so I I think that the evidence
is pretty clear there has been a real
world impact on positive Health outcomes
for people in 2018 we built a number of
Wellness incentives into the MCO provide
provision of service and so the Senate
heard testimony from the MCA bills and I
think you know hopefully you'll hear
that testimony today about how these
Health incentives are actually working
and should be a part of our
Health Care system in U.S a healthcare
professional no one ounce of prevention
is a heck of a lot better for the
individual than all the cures in the
world and if we can prevent illness that
should be our goal
other questions
oh follow oh I'm sorry representative
Merchant thank you Mr chairman thank you
Senator Bradley for taking the question
recently there's been because of the
pebble government there was expansion of
the Medicaid Program itself not so much
of this medical side of it
and we heard at the Department of Health
Human Services oversight committee the
Department's going through the process
of re-qualifying people for Medicaid
benefits
can you speak to how that may impact
those uh what I'm concerned about people
losing coverage
that we're trying to encourage here but
all of a sudden because what's going on
with the federal requirements that they
fall off the radar
so and I'm sure the department can
further answer this question but to try
to put it in a nutshell
because of a federal requirement during
the pandemic if you qualified for
Medicaid expansion you could not be
disenrolled if you no longer qualified
until the end of the emergency which
was April's first or March 31st so New
Hampshire has begun the process per
Federal Regulations of disenrolling
people who no longer qualify because
their income has exceeded the 138
percent of poverty
so that is a process that will occur
over time the department has estimated
that
um the historic Trend let me put it this
way up until the pandemic was between 50
and 52 000 people New Hampshire
residents on New Hampshire Medicaid
expansion that ballooned obviously
during the pandemic because no one could
be disenrolled up to over 90 000 people
the department estimates that that will
go back to about 60 to 65 000 people by
the end of the year but part of what the
Department of Health and Human Services
is doing as well as the department of
insurance is a very vigorous outreach
program to those people who no longer
income qualify to get them
for an opportunity to Avail themselves
of the health insurance that exists on
the exchanges which in all likelihood
they would qualify for or obviously at
this point they may qualify for employer
sponsored insurance so this change was
precipitated by the federal requirement
to not disenroll during the pandemic and
now the federal requirement that that
has ended so it's really outside of what
we've created in New Hampshire over the
years thank you
seeing no other question oh I'm sorry
representative pushman thank you Mr
chairman thank you again for taking my
question
um this one is on the commission to
evaluate the effectiveness and future of
the Granite Advantage Healthcare program
um
so can you explain what changes are
being made to that
um Commission in this bill
it's largely recreated
um representative Cushman
um
so
the and I chaired the
prior commission for several years that
issued a report last fall so it has
three members of the Senate three
members of the house
representative of various departments
Health and Human Services
Insurance representatives of the managed
care companies
hospitals a public member we've had
public members in the past
um
public member this time representing the
interest of small businesses I think
that's new
um we've had a licensed physician in the
past we've had other licensed Health
Care Professionals in the past
um I believe the
substance abuse disorder professional is
somebody that we haven't had in the past
the nurses I think have been represented
the chairperson of the alcohol and drug
prevention treatment I don't recall if I
was a member of doing this from memory
I'm sorry representative but I think
it's it's a broad
um
collection of Health Care Professionals
legislators and state officials at the
two departments that will
provide the necessary oversight on an
ongoing basis with a report that has to
be
written every year before November 1st
on or before so I think if people are
especially
with the thought hopefully that this
becomes permanent there should be
permanent oversight and I would like to
believe that this accomplishes that goal
follow up thank you for running through
that um so I'm wondering if there have
been some other study committee bills
coming through here and
um the actual voting members have been
restricted to members of the legislature
and then the other members like for
example
um you know if the mcos and public
members they served as advisory or um
could uh give input and and were listed
as you know we want input from these
people
um but the actual legislative action
taken is by
um members of the general court would
you be amenable to such a change so as I
recall and I'd have to go back and read
the prior statute but I think that was
the case in the um
Senate Bill 313 which I sponsored in
2018 that had only legislative members
voting as I recall that was the case
when I chaired it I tried to take all
voices and sort of tried to come to
consensus among all the members so to me
that's how it should work whether it's
specific to legislators only voting or a
vote of the entire commission I think
either way work for me it depends on you
know I think just whoever chairs it has
to be as inclusive to all voices as
possible okay thank you other questions
representative Weber
and just as a follow-up to
um representative cushman's questions
isn't it true that the function of this
committee is not a legislative one it is
evaluating writing reports and then
reporting to the legislature and others
so that further action if needed may be
taken by the legislature at that time
obviously that is what oversight is all
about representative Weber and thank you
for that question the
um
point I would make is that this is the
fourth version of Medicaid expansion
um
any member of the legislature can file a
bill at any point in time in the future
to make changes
um whether
this becomes permanent or is something
less than permanent I hope it will be
permanent but clearly the role of an
oversight committee is to provide that
kind of input back to and through the
three senators and three house members
for the other
418 members of the legislative body
I got my math right
424-6
this is why I sit on the Health and
Human Services committee and not the
finance committee that's a pretty easy
one I'm all right at addition and
subtraction sometimes representative
Merchant thank you Mr chair and thank
you senator for taking my question I'm
looking through a list of individuals on
the commission
it's very extensive
um one of the the parts that I think
could be added to it
drug therapy is a critical critical
component to healthcare but there's
nobody here from the world of Pharmacy
dealing with the issues that go on with
a major cost we look at the cost within
health care it's probably running 17 to
19 of the cost but there's nobody there
from the world of Pharmacy sitting on
the commission
I would take that as a friendly
other questions representative Cushman
last one thank you
um so
thinking now to you know we have some
people left out from it um
I just want to like so when we have this
exhaustive list and this is the issue
with other study committees and and
commissions
um it ends up inevitably leaving some
people out
um so that's why I made the point of you
know leave it open to advisory but I
don't see anything in here that
um directs this commission to take and
I'm sure that they could but would you
be open to
um an amendment to say that they take
um to me that always goes without saying
but of course that would be I would
consider that a friendly Amendment also
I mean when
um I chaired the commission we always
you know made sure to listen to folks
and I know you folks in this committee
do that every day and we try to do that
in the Senate but I would see both of
those as friendly amendments thank you
other questions
saying no other questions okay thank you
a couple of announcements uh just to
explain how we're going to proceed today
understandably we have quite a few folks
that want to testify in this bill it's a
very important bill and we want to make
sure you all have an opportunity to give
us your input accordingly and not the
only way we're going to do that is if we
limit testimony it's been our policy on
major pieces of legislation to what the
prime sponsor of extra time because
they're going through the the details of
the bill but after that we do ask that
those testifying limit that testimony to
three minutes and that will be enforced
after your three minutes is up I will
you know ask you to conclude or actually
I'll give you a little bit of a heads up
as you're approaching a few minutes ask
you to wrap up and then ask you if
you're going to take any questions from
the committee
also
um you know as we approach the lunchtime
hour I know that your time is valuable
my recommendation of the committee would
be that we continue uh until we're done
and members can take lunch as they at
their own discretion kind of like a
rolling lunches
the committee have any objections to
that
I know there's a budget uh informational
session later on this afternoon that
some may want to attend also so anyway
any questions at all committee members
especially a representative Weber
I just note that this is all taped so
members can fill in the gaps at a later
date unlike our prior procedures okay I
had an extra big breakfast because the
vice chairman is out and I I have nobody
to fill in for me so anyway
now with all of that being said um the
first person to testify is um mark bonta
okay
you know that you were free if you wish
to to designate anybody to present in
your absence if you would care to do
that not that you need to like it's
certainly been practicing in the past
American University
[Music]
again sir you were out in the hall but
you have three minutes um
would you state who where you're from
again because I just didn't catch it
yeah I'll start over yes sorry about
that my name is Mark bonta I'm the plant
director for Gen foot American Littleton
New Hampshire and I've been on the state
advisory Council for the recovery
friendly workplace since 2018.
um very passionate about the rfwi Mostly
because back in 2011 I had fired an
employee for reporting to work under the
influence of alcohol
and tragically within six months of
losing your job she passed away of liver
failure because she couldn't stop
drinking when I learned about the rfwi
it helped me to realize that there are
other options that I could have could
have taken with an employee that has
substance use disorder helping them get
into recovery instead of firing firing
them is namely
so in the past five years I've come to
realize that anybody that has a strength
of character to beat addiction is
somebody that I want working for me so
I've been working directly with Recovery
Home a recovery home local in Littleton
and I've hired dozens of employees from
that uh from that pool of applicants
some of them didn't work out but some of
them did and some of the success that
can be attributed in large part to the
support the mega kid expansion gave them
during the first few months of recovery
when we hire new employees and this is
most companies there's a three-month
typically a three-month probationary
period where they're not yet eligible
for health insurance and that uh the
first few months of recovery is crucial
to anyone getting into recovery because
they absolutely have to have treatment
in order to get the recovery off to a
good start and somebody needs to pay for
that treatment to fight addiction
the recovery-friendly workplace
initiative in New Hampshire is now 330
workplaces and over 90 000 employees
strong and the positive progress is
evident you can see it in some of the
data that's coming out in regards to
overdoses and and such
we are all working really hard to battle
addiction and we're winning the fight
but it's not over yet
um there's still a lot of work to be
done and we need to support the Medicaid
expansion gives us to continue the
positive progress we've been making
so please vote to continue that support
for us on a permanent basis
thank you thank you questions nope
questions any questions for this
gentlemen yes representative King
on your card you have that you have 20
copies of your testimony
has did that make everyone around
already I don't remember putting that on
a card was that something that we saved
so much I'm not sure
okay thank you
other questions
also signed up to testify is uh Steve
Anin from the New Hampshire Hospital
Association and John Skellington from
Parkland Medical Center
tomatoes to any gentleman you wanted to
come up together if that's okay sure
absolutely
so again three minutes you each have
good afternoon Mr chairman and members
of the committee thank you for the
opportunity to come up and testify with
uh John um jointly my name is Steve
bonnen I'm the president of New
Hampshire Hospital Association I'm here
representing all of our state's
hospitals John skevington as you noted
is the CEO of Parkland Medical Center in
Dairy you have my written testimony so I
won't go through it in its entirety but
there are a few points that I would like
to make
New Hampshire's hospitals have been have
been and continue to be partners with
the state in caring for our most
vulnerable citizens it is our mission to
care for those who are sick and our
members work tirelessly to provide the
highest quality care to all of our
patients regardless of their ability to
pay
New Hampshire's hospitals strongly
coverage to the Granite Advantage
Healthcare program allows patients to be
seen by a primary care doctor or in a
health clinic to receive important
primary and preventive cost-effective
management of chronic conditions and
life-saving mental health and substitute
services in short this coverage allows
these patients to receive the Right Care
in the right place at the right time
as Senator Bradley noted this program
has helped to reduce the number of
uninsured patients seeking Care at
hospital emergency rooms since the
Inception of the program hospitals
Statewide have seen a 63 percent
reduction in the number of uninsured
patients seeking care in the emergency
department a 58 reduction in the number
of uninsured inpatient Admissions and a
49 reduction in the number of uninsured
outpatient visits this has resulted in a
significant drop the amount of
uncompensated care attributable to those
without insurance in state fiscal year
2014 the first year of medic of New
Hampshire's Medicaid expansion program
hospitals reported 173 million dollars
in uncompensated care costs attributable
to those uh without insurance as a
result of Medicaid expansion those
uncompensated care costs have dropped
dramatically to 69 million in state
fiscal year 2021 a direct reflection of
the additional health insurance covered
provided by the granite Advantage
Healthcare program continuation of this
vital program is an important investment
in the health of our state and the
people it serves and we urge its
continued reauthorization we appreciate
the bipartisan support that the granted
Advantage Healthcare program has
received over the years and we offer our
strong support of Senate bill 263. again
thank you for the opportunity to share
our views I'd like to ask John to
scottington to make a few remarks and
then we'd be happy to answer questions
sir
good afternoon as noted my name is John
skevington I'm the CEO of Parkland
Medical Center in Derry New Hampshire
I'm also a Parkland Medical Center is
affiliated with HCA New Hampshire which
also includes Portsmouth Regional and
frisbee Memorial Hospitals
in 2022 together our three hospitals and
2600 staff members delivered Health Care
to Residents throughout the granite
state in over half a million patient
encounters
with the benefits provided by granted
Advantage our uncompensated care for our
three hospitals which totaled over 14
million dollars was able to be decreased
by eight percent from the prior year
in large part due to granted advantage
why is this important to us over the
last two years hospitals have weathered
tremendous challenges and we continue to
see uncertainties and Rising costs
around Workforce supply chain and
capital costs reauthorizing granted
Advantage would help create some
certainty in a very uncertain climate
for Health Systems
reauthorization is not just important
for hospitals but also for the
communities we serve there are
businesses and providers in our
communities who rely on granted
advantage to continue to serve patients
and provide preventative care for those
patients
your support of this important program
will help many of your constituents in
your Community Hospitals and in
conclusion I add my voice with the New
Hampshire Hospital Association in
support of Medicaid expansion
reauthorization thank you thank you
questions
I'm representative Shapiro
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking this question
um
I've read that the New Hampshire fiscal
policy Institute has
um estimated that
3.23 billion dollars has come into the
state through Medicaid expansion during
the whole time of Medicaid expansion so
that's a lot of money and
um
for both unreimbursed care what would
have been unreimbursed care and other
um kind of Cascades down the line when
we when we talk about tax policy there's
always a lot of emphasis on how
important it is for businesses to know
what the policy is going to be going out
years and years because of the need to
plan and I know that right now there's a
debate about whether this should be
permanent as this bill says or whether
it should be
two years or something in between so my
question is really how important is
um how important is passing Medicaid
expansion that is permanent or long-term
in terms of
fiscal planning for medical institutions
I'll start um I would say it's very
important that we have that level of
stability so that we understand what
that will look like it's important for
hospitals but also think about the small
independent provider the small practice
um someone providing Behavioral Health
Services seeing patients who are covered
by Medicaid expansion not knowing
whether those patients would continue to
be covered through insurance would be a
really challenging thing for them to
plan to whether they could continue to
serve those those patients there are
other uh you know issues of importance
for for the health plans to be able to
understand that they that's going to be
a longer term contract I know that there
will be others who will speak to that
issue but again we think that that
that's an important piece and the
senator Bradley note of the program has
certainly stood the test of time and as
we all know um any legislator can
introduce a bill at any point in time to
make a change to a program so we believe
removing that sunset provision isn't is
is an appropriate thing with the the
level of oversight that will continue
no I think Steve answered that very
eloquently I have nothing further ad
thank you other questions
so you know other questions okay thank
also signed up to speak is Henry lippman
from the Department of Health and Human
Services
for the record Henry Littman States
Medicaid director I'd like to make three
points so we make sure I stay within the
three minutes the the term of
reauthorization is important in terms of
getting value for the procurement we're
currently due to re-procure the contract
during 24 fiscal year and I think it's
important to have a a term that allows
mcos who may be bidding for the contract
to have a reasonable expectation that
their upfront Investments and building
compliance with the contract that
they'll get a return on that and so I
think that's one point the second point
I'd like to make is sort of to tie to
what Senator Bradley was saying earlier
that Medicaid expansion as a program is
not just good for within the Medicaid
Program that's been very good for the
insurance markets in New Hampshire as as
Senator talked about what effectively
Medicaid expansion does for our
insurance markets is a population that
has maybe a different utilization level
than other parts of the market is an out
of the other risk basis which allows
better pricing and I think where we see
we have a we're number one in the
country a number of people covered by
employee sponsored insurance and we have
the lowest Benchmark premium
um on the exchange and I think it's you
have to look at this is part of I think
a policy tool not only to help people
around Medicaid but it's helping
everyone in the in the state and finally
um on a matter of uh quality and
Workforce we've actually seen during the
the period of two before the federal
Public Health Emergency today
Senator Bradley talked about 70 percent
of the Medicaid population working
that's higher than pre-pandemic levels
and lastly in terms of quality we do
track a lot of metrics uh about 300 on
the program all told them we have a
website if you'd like to look at that
but I would mention a couple things that
generally in Medicaid there are areas
where we even outperform the the
commercial market in terms of the Care
Management that's with the program just
one example is control of diabetes and
the common
H1 AC
Dimension that the rates for New
Hampshire Medicaid are higher than in in
other parts of the market and also in
terms of the important Services of
follow-up after an emergency room for
either mental health and sud condition
um higher than than the New Hampshire
commercial Market with that I'll stop
and take any questions thank you very
much
questions oh yes representative Murphy
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question my question is I
believe that you have
if I'm not mistaken three MCO contracts
uh in the Medicaid Program is that
correct that is correct and how long how
long does each contract usually
negotiate for yeah and the program has
been five year terms and how challenging
would it be to go to two years or how
beneficial as a conversely stated you
know would it be to allow this to be a
permanent change at house division three
I testified the concern I had was with a
two-year reauthorization that was talked
about there is that it would actually
only amount to one year
um under the procurement
thank you
other questions
representative Weber
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question I was scribbling as
fast as I could but I missed your point
number three which was about the
workforce and then I missed the last
part of that so in terms of Workforce
the 70 number that uh
Senator Bradley referenced that was in
the Kaiser report if you go back and
look at 2019 report that actually the
number of people are working in the
Medicaid within Medicaid is higher today
than it was
um before the pandemic okay thank you
very much and the second point was
regarding the
um
representative Merchant
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
the question MS lippin
earlier I asked the question to Senator
Bradley my concern is that for the last
two years it has been sort of an
emergency Federal order to protect
Medicaid people from income issues and
it could be taken up Medicaid because of
that however that's been changeable I
think it's May 11th or the next nine
months the Department's going to go
through that reevaluation process my
concern is
what impact it's going to have on those
individuals that may not qualify and
then what can the department do to try
to help them apply for
individual coverage or supplement them
I'm just concerned for like
25 30 000 people that may not qualify
what can we do about that
so we've been doing a lot and um just in
the interest of time here I think let me
just
um highlight a few of the sort of the
key ones is that an individual that's
over income that completes their
redetermination we automatically refer
them to the federal exchange so that
they can be picked up on we went further
than that we were the first state in the
country to approach socio which is the
the agency within the federal HHS to be
able to actually people who in the past
would do nothing about that that their
application would just sort of be like a
dead letter wouldn't go anywhere and so
now we have a mechanism to communicate
back so that those individuals can be
picked up and offered the opportunity
there's a special enrollment period
available to people who lose their
Medicaid they have between now excuse me
between April 1st and July of 24 and so
we've been working extensively with the
states navigate us through the New
Hampshire insurance department we've
been working extensively with the mcos
and they've we've given them their
patients list so that they can do
Outreach we've worked with Community
Mental Health Centers fqhcs and giving
them their patient list to let them know
in detail what individuals they're
caring for that have a redetermination
that's outstanding one just wants to two
statistics quick statistics we never
stop like some states processing
applications or asking people
voluntarily to complete their
redetermination we had about 103 000
people at the end of March that were
protected by the continuous enrollment
we'd actually we're concerned about how
many people would be affected so we
worked for a couple years to get people
to do it voluntarily we've got over 32
000 people to complete their
determination on a voluntary basis
thereby reducing the workload so that we
can catch give people the attention they
deserve and then secondly
uh people have let us know over I think
3 300 people now maybe 3 500 have let us
know that they no longer need Medicaid
because they have based on our Outreach
um and uh you know we're we're uh we're
doing all we can I think we you know
we've come at this we don't want anybody
to lose coverage that that qualifies
um and those that can't we're trying to
look help them find other options
thank you I just want a quick comment I
want to say much appreciate your
involvement of what you're doing in the
department as well going my opinion
above and beyond what's probably
required I think it's um the human
humanistic side of the department that I
see which is thank you thank you other
questions yes representative Coachman
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
um so thinking about the MCO contracts
and I'm sure that they're
in addition to you know the the funds
that come from the state and federal
government to pay for the actual care
there's probably a baseline
um compensation for the mcos for the
administrative costs
um do you know what those are per
enrollee per day I don't have an on a
per day basis I can give you on a
percentage basis and and roughly what I
what came out in dollars in the most
recent contract but basically um you
know when I was in front of governor and
Council
um one of the key things that I'm always
facing when I come to Governor council
is you know the challenge of how much
we're paying for administration you know
we're currently paying
um among the lowest I think in the
country with respect to to the
administrative costs we're paying
between for the administrative component
depending on the eligibility class
between 7.4 and 8.3 percent of the the
capitation rate
um there's built-in
um on top of that we we spend about 90
percent of the dollars our Medical Care
um two percent is for the premium tax
and one and a half percent is the
built-in Actuarial margin into the into
the program and it's it's very lean and
and uh we I think that we've spent
um with the enrollment at in this
current uh amendment that we're
operating under we're about a quarter of
a million individuals today
um in total in the program not just
expansion but the entire program it was
about 105 million dollars in an
out of a 1.3 billion plus contract
other questions
saying no other questions okay thank you
also signed up to speak is Senator Cindy
and Senator you put down five minutes if
you can keep it to three I'd appreciate
it okay thank you yeah thank you Mr
chairman members of the committee for
the record I'm Cindy Rosenwald from
Senate District 13. I'm here to speak in
strong supportive Senate bill 263. this
program not only benefits the health of
tens of thousands of New Hampshire
residents it's also a very significant
pro-business program because a healthy
working age population is an employable
population
since its Inception in 2014 Medicaid
expansion has been a Lifeline for
hospitals particularly the small rural
ones reducing uncompensated care as
Senator Bradley said
uncompensated care leads to higher
premiums for people who have private
insurance
and because the federal government funds
almost all of it Medicaid expansion is a
significant economic driver last year
alone it represented a 500 million
dollar investment in our state's economy
the program has several built-in
safeguards for taxpayers Senator Bradley
spoke of removing a perspective repeal
as making the the program permanent
strictly speaking that's not the case as
the U.S Supreme Court
um issued an opinion
more than 10 years ago now as a waiver
program is completely voluntary
while no state has stopped Medicaid
expansion all of them could and New
Hampshire could stop Medicaid expansion
by notifying CMS that we wanted to
winding down the waiver it would
probably take six or nine months but
there's
there's not really permanency in it
because it's a voluntary program and
it's a waiver program
I've been honored to work with Senator
Bradley
on this program since its Inception in
actually we started working on probably
in 2012.
granted advantages and extremely
successful program and I think we need
to reauthorize it thank you I'm happy to
take questions
thank you Senator questions
representative Cushman
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
being here Senator
um I want to know your opinion what do
you make of the recent statement the
recommendations released by the
Congressional budget office
that due to the federal deficit
um and and the immense amount of debt
that we're dealing with federally that
they recommend that the states
and the federal government decrease
Medicaid enrollment and increase the
state portion of funding for Medicaid
and how does that impact the future of
this legislation well in terms of this
program then 90 Federal contribution is
not by regulation it is in federal
statute it can only be changed by an act
of Congress
and let me just say that the federal
government has never ever not made good
on its promises for paying their
percentage of Medicaid costs in fact
several times since I've been in the
legislature over the past nine and a
half terms the federal government has
increased its proportion of matching
funds either for children for the last
few years for
all of Medicaid except for a Medicaid
expansion so I really don't see
any change in the federal matching
percentage for this program
follow up
thank you
um well I'm concerned when you what do
you make of the effect that this will
have on on national debt and inflation
because the federal government is
picking up more of the tab and with the
increase in spending we're printing more
money we have a higher deficit now than
we ever have you know Nationwide this is
an issue and it impacts us here in the
granite state do you have any
trepidation about that
thank you for the question I'm not an
economist but I think with
um
lots of other changes in the world and
in federal law over the last four or
five years there are many other things
that have contributed to federal debt
rather than Medicaid expansion in the
like 40 states that have done it
other questions
so you know other questions
oh I'm sorry representative Weber uh
thank you Mr chairman I just have one
for you and and that is is this bill
going to finance after it finishes with
us yes it is okay thank you
that's reassuring thank you thank you
senator
uh next uh person signed up to testify
is a Doug McNutt from the state
again sorry you have three minutes
no chicken
microphone
yep put your microphone on please
so is it on okay for record my name is
Doug McNutt I'm a member of the state
Commission on Aging I serve with
representative Weber on that Commission
in the past I've worked for AARP and I
also work for the Department of Health
and Human Services and division of
elderly Adult Services I come here today
representing the state Commission on
Aging who is in support of this bill
I've passed out written testimony and I
want to just talk about a couple of
things that probably
um some of the other
testifiers won't be mentioning I'm going
to focus on the category of people that
are 56 to 64 that are taking advantage
of Medicaid
expansion that's a population for home
health insurance is very expensive they
are people who oftentimes have lost jobs
and at that age it's very difficult to
get the next job this program is a
lifesaver for those people in terms of
keeping them healthy so that they can
and continue to work and take on that
next job at this point and I the figures
from last year indicate about 15 percent
of the people on Medicaid expansion are
from that age group and they are
particularly vulnerable group of people
and this program is critical for them
the other thing I want to mention
briefly is that this is also helpful for
caregivers
in terms of taking care of people who
are in that age bracket and
significantly older this helps the
workforce situation and the people who
are low wage are able to get health
insurance and when they need it and it
is also helpful in terms of that regard
so those are the two principal things
that I wanted to focus on and I'd be
happy to answer any questions you might
have
thank you questions for Mr McNutt
also signed up to speak is Greg Moore
again sir you have three minutes
thank you Mr chair members of the
committee I'll make this as brief as
possible uh there's two issues as a
sponsoring side relative to this bill
one is to the merits of Medicaid
expansion and the second subsidiary
issue is uh what time duration if there
should be an expansion should it last
those are the two fundamental issues
here I'll address both in the first
instance in the first instance and by
the way uh this is actually the fifth
time we've done Medicaid expansion
there's 2013 2014 2016 2018 and now and
uh I also want to point one thing out
which is the uh the Senator Senator how
the speakers have mentioned a drop in in
health insurance costs
I will say that I monitor this pretty
closely and the correlation to that
appears to be with an insurance waiver
that the Department of Insurance filed
in 2018 relative to setting up a
Statewide reinsurance pool and that that
correlates much more closely with the
drop in health insurance costs than the
2014 expansion of Medicaid but America's
Prosperity uh poses this legislation and
it does so for a couple of reasons first
and foremost first and foremost as this
sponsor mentioned uh there is concern
about the impact of a welfare or
benefits Cliff we know this is a big
issue it's an issue that's been
discussed in both left and right and I
know the department issued a report on
this very issue last week oddly enough
they seem to they seem to tackle every
means tested welfare program in the
state except for Medicaid which I find
is a little bit of an outlier but uh
it's not so much whether people work or
not work as a sponsor said the question
is whether people will work further take
a job that pays a little more seek out
more hours that's really the challenge
is the benefit Cliffs impact that aspect
not whether the binary decision as to
what whether or not to work
so we think that's an important factor
for the for the committee to consider
the second factor for the committee to
consider is the impact of all the
induced demand they're putting hundreds
of millions of dollars of new money into
the HealthCare Marketplace makes
now we do know it reduces uncompensated
care there's no question that it reduces
uncompensated care but we're spending
500 million dollars a year on Medicaid
expansion and the reduction in
uncompensated cares is well less than
that the the other money represents an
uh induced demand that is uh causing
more utilization that utilization has
put a strain on our on our health care
Workforce and we have now have provider
shortages across the state when I worked
at the department provider shortages
were something that were fairly rare
sometimes within unique fields and and
particularly in the Northern parts of
the state now we see them widespread
across the state and this induced demand
does have an impact on that the second
issue relative to the time frame uh I as
to whether or not this should be
permanent or as the house finance
committee recommended a more temporary
expansion of Medicaid and what I was
what I would say to that is I do expect
there will be Federal action I know this
because a former boss of mine that
representative McKay knows well and our
Pacific McDonald knows well has been
talking with members of Congress and
there is an effort a foot to look for
ways to try to bring reforms to it a lot
of those reforms look like some of the
reforms that represent McKay would
remember from TANF which is such as uh
allow allowing for the provision of work
requirement New Hampshire does have a
work requirement law but it's been
disallowed by the federal courts in
other words changing the federal law to
allow work requirements and potentially
a lifetime benefit cap similar to what's
what's been in place with TANF so for
those reasons we think it's important
for us to consistently refresh and look
back at this program and to determine
and determine whether we need to make
adaptations as we did with the TANF
program tanfree authorization back in
2006 and Justice TANF is reauthorized we
should be doing the same with with uh
with Medicaid expansion as well and
because I do expect there will be
Federal action at some point because
it's not wrapping up please absolutely
so with that I'll leave it there and
I'll be happy to take any questions from
the committee thank you any questions
from Mr Moore representative Shapiro
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking the question you talked about
um
that you seem to be advocating for a
shorter term reauthorization because
there might be changes coming along and
we should be able to be nimble to adjust
to those changes
uh representative uh we we opposed the
program and it's in totality however
what I was saying is that the house
finance committee that with the budget
you'll be voting on on Thursday right um
has a a shorter duration a two-year
extension uh for Medicaid expansion
relative to this legislation I was
comparing and contrasting to two
approaches follow up follow up well
isn't it true that if this is made
permanent
um if this bill is the bill that
predominates and it's made permanent
um couldn't changes be made in any case
just by introducing the legislation
that's certainly a prospect but uh if
you look at the this would be the third
reauthorization so 2016 2018 and now
2023. uh every time that there have been
that this has been reauthorized there
have been major changes to the program
so it creates a consistent inflection
point for the legislature to look to
take action so we think that we think
that's a healthy approach
thank you
other questions
say no other questions thank you thank
you
also signed up to speak is former
thank you for the record my name is Tom
Sherman I'm a physician in Exeter and a
former State Rep and state senator and
it's I always feel like I'm coming home
when I come back to health and human
services and elderly Affairs I see my
former Vice chair and my former chair
and it's just great to be here with you
all
um what I'm first of all my background
on Medicaid expansion is that I was on
the original commission that created the
bipartisan proposal for Medicaid
expansion that included as
representative Cushman alluded to the
circuit breakers that that's what we
call them the taxpayer protections that
are in the Bill currently
and that also anticipated the need to
have expiration dates or reauthorization
dates and one of the circuit breakers
just to address representative Kushner
cushman's earlier question was that the
program would automatically go into a
reauthorization if the federal component
dropped below 90 percent so I think that
was one of the reassurances that we had
and continue to have whether or not this
is made permanent that circuit breaker
focus on today very quickly is
the human side it's also the fiscal side
when I was practicing
before Medicaid expansion two patients
really stood out to me one of them had
ulcerative colitis it was actually very
easily treated with an oral medication
that he couldn't afford and as a result
of not being able to afford it he was
bouncing in the hospital in and out of
the hospital about every six weeks
he lost his job he lost his home his
family was dependent completely on
public assistance
but with Medicaid expansion having seen
the before and after as his provider
not only did he recover his job
and his health but his home and the
interesting part to this is that
he went off Public Assistance went off
Medicaid and was able to be fully
self-sufficient once he got his health
back
the second one was more poignant for me
it was a woman who not only lost her job
her home
but also her family
she was homeless and we took everybody
at core gastroenterology and she walked
in with multiple medical problems only
one of which was in my specialty
but through Medicaid expansion and
getting her that coverage with the full
complement of 10 essential services
not only did she recover her health
after Medicaid expansion but she also
recovered her home and eventually her
family
the point here is that real people these
are Granite Staters these are our
neighbors our families
these aren't people as as rep as a
director Lipman pointed out 70 percent
are working
these are people who are working they
want to work they want to be out in the
job market we need them in the job
market please stop wrapping up but the
most important Point here is that this
is the key to getting them back into the
workforce and getting them their dignity
their life and their economic stability
back so I appreciate your vote I
strongly support this I always have and
you will be saving lives when you pass
this thank you thank you you're taking
questions sure any questions yes about
President of Cushman thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question
um it's a simple one uh do you know what
the work requirement is exactly is there
an hour a number of hours per week that
is required of the enrollees it's my
understanding that there is no work
requirement currently because the
federal courts actually struck down the
work requirements in other states even
though we passed a work requirement it
couldn't be implemented because of
federal that's my understanding you can
check that I'm sure representative I'm
sorry director Lipman would know the
answer to that
other questions
I'm saying none thank you oh I'm sorry
so it would be your would it be your
testimony that we are succeeding and
returning people to the workforce
despite the fact that the work
requirement is not currently being
enforced absolutely and you know when
you look at the income levels that allow
you to qualify for Medicaid expansion
then think about trying to live
at that income and also manage your own
health care
costs it's it's daunting
but all of my patients who have come in
on Medicaid expansion have gotten the
exact same care as commercial carriers
patients covered by commercial carriers
they have been working and one other
point is that I I'm sure you know of the
Oregon study that was done through
Harvard
that study showed that one of the first
benefits is that economic stability that
allows people to go back to work
and I think that's really important we
understand the impact of Health Care
bills it breaks people's home budget
completely
so having this as a as a tool it doesn't
keep people off work it actually gets
them back to work and off of Public
Assistance and that is has been my
clinical experience in my own practice
thank you
and welcome back thank you it's great to
be here
other questions
also signed up to speak is Peggy Gilmore
thank you Mr chairman it is like old
home week and you do have three minutes
yes thank you uh thank you chairman
McDonald and members of the committee uh
for the record I'm Peggy Gilmore from
pretty strategies but here today
representing the greater Nashua Chamber
of Commerce Wendy Hunter our president
and CEO had very much hope to be here to
testify because this bill is a number
one priority for the national Chamber of
Commerce but she's winging her way home
from Greece as we speak so that
took priority uh the greater Nashua
Chamber of Commerce represents over 400
business members that are large they're
small they're poor profit non-profit
every sector manufacturing Hospitality
health care and and this is a very
important business related Bill you'll
hear a lot about the health uh
improvements that have come through
Medicaid expansion I'm here just to talk
about why it's so important to the
businesses and we know that we've heard
over and over again that we're lacking
in many instances of work ready
Workforce a healthy Workforce ready
um
lack of insurance is the biggest
deterrent to both preventative and
necessary particularly for chronic
health conditions Health Care
greater Nashua has two major Hospital
Systems we have Home Care
Mental Health Providers substance abuse
providers all of these are major
Employers in the greater Nashua area
without Medicaid expansion these
employers lose significant funding and
the members of those that are uninsured
as you've heard repeatedly will rise
dramatically and you've heard that the
data on uncompensated care costs will
rise and those costs are then passed on
to the private insurance contracts and
then to the employer who offers health
insurance and then to the employee in
the form of higher premiums that they
get from their their work environment
Senator Bradley has referred to this as
a hidden tax and he's absolutely correct
this is exactly what this is cost
shifting is a hidden tax
and finally again as you've heard and
we'll hear repeatedly Senate Bill 263
calls for permanent reauthorization we
know that what our businesses want and
ask consistently from our government is
stability and predictability
to limit authorization to two years or
four years or six years threatens that
predictability so on behalf of the
strong business community of the SEC
State's second largest city and all of
its surrounds we ask that you find
Senate Bill 263 permanently authorizing
Medicaid expansion
ought to pass
and you could follow the sentence
send its way and do it unanimously
so I thank you for your time and for
your attention to this important bill
and we'll take any questions that you
may have thank you questions for Senator
Gilmore
also signed up to speak is Sam Hawkins
thank you chairman and committee members
for the opportunity to testify today in
three minutes sir yeah
my name is Sam Hawkins I'm the public
policy assistant at Nami New Hampshire
the National Alliance on Mental Illness
the Nami New Hampshire is a non-profit
Grassroots organization whose mission is
to improve the lives of all people
impacted by mental illness and suicide
through support education and advocacy
on behalf of Nami I'm here today to
speak in strong support of Senate bill
263. alongside my written testimony I've
passed along written testimony from
constituent who really wanted to be here
but unfortunately was unable
of all the challenges facing Granite
Staters our Mental Health crisis is
Paramount in New Hampshire 221 000
adults have a mental health condition
and fifteen thousand minors ages 12 to
17 have depression
despite the availability of effective
treatment over half the individuals
living with a mental health condition in
the U.S do not receive treatment
like other mental illnesses
like other medical illnesses delays in
treatment mean progression of the
seriousness of the illness
and more difficulty in cost when the
person does eventually receive treatment
for those living with a mental illness
these delays can result in outstanding
personal and productive losses that harm
their livelihoods and could be
life-threatening in 2021 of the adults
in New Hampshire who did not receive
Mental Health Care nearly 42 percent did
not because of cost
increasing access to care is crucial in
addressing New Hampshire's Mental Health
crisis and reducing the human Financial
cost of untreated mental illness on our
state Nam New Hampshire applauds the
current success of the New Hampshire
granted Advantage Healthcare program and
the efforts to reauthorize it in
perpetuity
of impact of this program the positive
impact this program has in improving
access to care is obvious in 2021
through the Medicaid expansion program
over 11
000 Unique Individuals received mental
health outpatient services nearly 830
accessed inpatient psychiatric
hospitalization and over 26 500 obtained
mental health medication regarding our
Rising rates of Youth mental illness
research shows that more children are
covered by Insurance in states with
Medicaid expansion than in those without
this program also goes a long way in
addressing our state's substance use
crisis as more than seven thousand
individuals in the program sought
substance use disorder outpatient
services
7500 engaged with medication assisted
treatment and 2 300 obtained inpatient
or residential sud treatment
SB 263 which reauthorizes The crucial
and successful New Hampshire granted
Advantage Health Care Program is one of
the most impactful measures the
legislature can employ in supporting
Granite Staters for these reasons Nami
strongly encourages the committee to
vote ought to pass if I can take any
questions thank you
expressions
any questions from committee members
also signed up to speak is Chris
good afternoon
good afternoon I hope you won't hear my
stomach growling
we want to listen to your stomach growl
if you don't listen to iOS fair
and Mr chairman and members of the
committee my name is Chris McCracken and
I serve as the CEO at Emma skate health
and I think we are the maybe the largest
federally qualified Health Center in the
State located in Manchester New
Hampshire and so it kind of presenting
this from the perspective of a patient
care provider and a care provider that
is focused on a population of people who
have limited income and resources to
provide themselves access to care at our
organization 43 of our patients do not
speak English as their primary language
we serve the largest number of
beneficiaries of the Granite State
Advantage Health Care Program of all of
the fqhc's federally qualified health
centers in New Hampshire over 50 percent
of our patients are insured through this
program
in the last five years we've seen a 12
percent increase in patients and 116
percent increase in the number of
patients seeking sud services
and we know that the members of our
community and the communities that you
represent have better access to health
care services that they desperately need
when they have insurance and I'd like to
demonstrate that through a patient care
story I always think that's the most
impactful way to think about a program
such as this this is a story that our
associate medical director of Family
Practice shared with our team and I
thought it was really poignant and I
thought it would make sense to share
with you she had a patient that was in
his mid-50s that she had been providing
health care for for over 15 years
construction worker great guy but
suffered with diabetes and Sugar's
constantly out of control constantly out
of control couldn't do anything to kind
of get them established and after the
implementation of the Granite State
advantage and Medicaid expansion in New
Hampshire suddenly his number started to
come down and come down and she said all
right I gotta ask I don't know what we
did differently this time but suddenly
it's working and he said because I can
afford my medication I can afford my
test strips I'm testing regularly I'm
taking the medication as you prescribe
it I'm not cutting my doses suddenly
he's doing it excellently his sugar is
controlled and this has really enabled
him that ability to stabilize his health
and stay out of the hospital and not
lose a limb not lose his eyesight so
you can see that that impact for
managing chronic disease and so many
individuals face that and the older we
get the more of those we Face I'll
include myself in that group it's a
really critical mechanism and she often
says you know if it weren't for Medicaid
expansion so many of my patients I would
not be able to help them effectively
manage their care because when I come to
the doctor I'm probably going to need a
test or I'm probably going to need a
medicine and how am I going to be able
to afford that if I don't have a
mechanism and people make horrible
horrible choices about oh can I afford
my rent or can I pay my gas or can I buy
this medicine that I so desperately need
we can start wrapping up please that was
really the point of what I wanted to say
so I will stop there thank you if you
have any questions I'm happy to try and
answer them sure questions from
committee members
also signed up to speak is Lisa Brett
solski Stevens for ES New Hampshire
Vermont Farnham Easter Seals I'm sorry
well
good to see you again thank you it's
nice to be seeing you good afternoon
again you have three minutes yeah for
the record I'm Lisa Britt solsky Stevens
I'm the chief of government relations
and compliance for Easter Seals New
Hampshire Vermont and Farnham today I
want to talk to you about Farnum in
particular it's one of 14 programs and
services that Easter Seals manages
um just a note about Easter Seals in New
Hampshire we're in the top five largest
Affiliates of Easter Seals in the
country We Touch about 20 000
individuals across the granite in Green
Mountain States and we're the 12th
largest employer in New Hampshire
so Farnam as you may know is a carf
accredited substance misuse Treatment
Facility in Manchester we do inpatient
and outpatient treatment at two
locations Our Queen City app location is
a 24 by 7 residential treatment facility
and Farnam has been doing substance use
treatment for over 35 years
Burnham services are evidence-based
which is something critical in this
field
our staff just completed training at
Hazelton Betty Ford foundation so that
they can do co-occurring treatment it's
estimated that 80 percent of people in
substance abuse treatment also have
mental illness this will position Farnum
well to be able to manage the whole
person instead of bisecting between
mental illness and substance misuse I
see representative McKay nodding
knowingly
just this last weekend
um
our payer mix in detox was 78 Medicaid
and in residential treatment it was 89
Medicaid and this is typical at Freedom
our next largest payer is the Bureau of
drug and alcohol services with whom we
have a contract and it reimburses less
than Medicaid does
asking why Farnham served so many people
on Medicaid as akin to asking what came
first the chicken or the egg
focusing on the Medicaid population
allows us to sub-specialize on the
social determinants of Health that
underpin Medicaid eligibility
this is the space that we proudly
the overwhelming majority of our
patients benefit from the granted
Advantage Program so recall 87 and 89
percent of our census was Medicaid the
majority of those are granted advantage
and one need not be the chair of house
finance to understand that if the
granite Advantage goes away Farnham
becomes extremely precarious
permanent reauthorization is
contemplated in this bill is needed for
safety net provides providers like
Farnham who do not have the ability to
do robust cross-subsidization across
payers
our ability to plan for the future for
sustainability requires that we know
that our primary source of funding is
intact
in the absence of Farnam who will
welcome 300 3000 or more low-income
individuals for treatment for which they
cannot pay each year
we all know that those folks will go
without necessary care
they will miss the opportunity to get
back on their feet return to family and
work stronger and healthier
National estimates are that 110 000
individuals died last year of overdoses
this does not include deaths due to
cumulative impacts of addiction which
are what my father succumbed to last
summer at age 70 and my sister-in-law
succumbed to last November at age 55.
you could please stop wrapping up
my sister-in-law lived in Florida while
she was fighting cancer they don't have
the Medicaid expansion she sold her home
before going to hospice in order to pay
the Mayo Clinic
New Hampshire needs Farnham Farnam needs
the reauthorization it saves lives thank
you happy to take any questions thank
you
also signed up to speak as Regina Pike
good afternoon good afternoon uh you
have three minutes okay thank you
a little nervous but sure I can do it
so good afternoon my name is Regina Pike
from Rochester but everybody calls me
Gina I'm here on behalf of myself and
many others who are on the credit
Advantage Health Plan before divorce I
never heard of the plan post Awards I
lost my insurance and had to choose
between getting medical care that I
needed or accruing medical debt since I
was a caretaker still to my parents I
applied for assistance and the granted
Advantage was the only program that I
could qualify for due to my age plus not
being labeled disabled through SSI
with the grand Advantage Program I don't
have to choose between care slash debt I
get to choose my health recovery over
being on the couch not knowing what my
illnesses are without the granted
Advantage Program being available to me
I wouldn't be here right now standing up
for myself and many others that are
affected by this
proposal to make it permanent I wouldn't
be able to afford the treatment for my
invis invisible disabilities including
mental health issues brain injury
challenges and my other medical
conditions I wouldn't have to be able to
I I wouldn't have been able to go to
Boston for treatments and then get
reimbursed for mileage that Medicaid
does right now I get Vision treatment
post-concussion
um getting out of an abusive
relationship with therapy helping
finding my diagnosis of ptfd depression
anxiety ADHD and to be able to go to
work
at my own pace as a member of the
Seacoast Pathways a clubhouse they are
mental health non-profit that helps
people get back to work
with my conditions I can't focus on
getting healthier as well as getting
back to work at the same time so taking
care of my health because of the great
Innovations program has helped me be
able to work part-time I doordash
because my parents recently passed away
so this helps me get back to work and to
be able to have the services I need and
the support for
me to have a healthier life for the rest
of my life because I'm only 39.
so
I propose that you say yes to keeping
this program and to keep it permanent so
I don't have to have the anxiety of
just waiting for it to end or to I read
determination all the time and I get
anxiety from that so I don't need the
anxiety of having that plus waiting to
see if this is over you know like with
our notices what we got it was anxiety
provoking so if you have any questions I
can answer
thank you any questions
say no questions okay thank you very
also signed up to speak is Peter Mason
Mr chairman and hungry members of the
committee
my name is Peter Mason I'm here
representing the medical society and
headrest I'm a family physician and I've
practiced in Lebanon for over 40 years
since 2005 I've worked extensively with
individuals struggling with substance
use disorders and I'm currently the
medical director of headrest an
outpatient and Transitional Living
facility for people in recovery with
offices in Lebanon and a sober living
house in Boston approximately 90 percent
of the individuals I care for are
covered by Medicaid when Medicaid
expansion became effective in 2014 it
enabled them to access to have access to
treatment for their substance use
disorders as well as for other chronic
physical and emotional illnesses
suddenly they were able to establish
with pcps and get preventative and
continuity care rather than presenting
to emergency rooms in crisis when their
problems were more advanced lead to more
expensive inefficient and episodic care
as a result Medicaid expansion has
decreased the burden of illness and it
saved countless dollars
as bad as a healthcare system is today
it's hard to imagine how much worse
things would be without Medicaid
expansion
I've delivered hundreds of babies but
equally rewarding is the work I do with
people in recovery
to see them stabilize get their lives
back together engage in productive work
reunite with the loved ones and stay out
of trouble is incredibly gratifying many
of these individuals have a history of
incarceration
now their productive tax paying members
of society we need to make Medicaid
expansion permanent without the clarity
of funding that permanent
reauthorization provides not only the
agency I work for but also so many other
Health and Social Service Providers
would not be able to continue their work
and most importantly the people we're
serving will lose the care that they so
desperately need please support this
legislation and I'm happy to take any
questions
thank you any questions
also signed up to speak is Bob Dunn from
Londonderry representing the Roman
and as since London area is the
community I'm privileged to represent
always happy to see somebody from London
here
thank you Mr chair
thank you for your service thank you the
town of Londonderry
um good afternoon I'm Bob Dunn the
director of public policy for the Roman
Catholic Diocese of Manchester and I'm
here today on behalf of Bishop Peter
labashi
and also on behalf of Catholic Medical
Center and New Hampshire Catholic
Charities to register our support for
Senate bill 263. I have just two quick
comments to make
first
a bill like this is important for a
number of reasons and one of them is
that it uh once again
re-emphasizes the fundamental place of
the principle of the common good and
you've heard me say in front of this
committee before that it's important for
us to remember that the principle of the
common good is not just a religious
sentiment but it is at the heart of the
Constitutional order that was left us by
the framers of the Constitution part one
article one of the New Hampshire
Constitution says that that government
was instituted for the general good
second
um it's clear from what you've heard and
what you will hear that the granite
Advantage program has improved the live
lives of tens and tens and tens of
thousands of New Hampshire citizens
and there are many people obviously who
are alive today because of the health
care that they received undergraded
advantage that seems obvious
and so manifestly in our view Senate
Bill 263 is a bill that can and should
now the Medicaid Program may not be
perfect but we think that this bill
boils down to just one question
what would be the mechanism for
providing Health Care to the Granite
Advantage population
if Granite Advantage were to disappear
and since we all know what the answer to
that question is we think that and we
ask we think that Senate Bill 263 is a
good idea and we ask you to vote ought
to pass thank you thank you
any questions yes representative King
thank you Mr chairman and uh thank you
for taking my question
um through the whole Medicaid process
that we've gone through this session
I've I've been asking the question where
the churches fit in in helping out with
some of our societal issues that we have
well the the from the Catholic Church's
perspective the um the church and the
state have an obligation to work
together to serve the common good
um and in fact we believe that the
Catholic church in New Hampshire through
its um diocese and through its parishes
and institutions is second only to the
state of New Hampshire as a provider of
charitable care
um so it's I think something where both
sides need to do their work
I think the churches are doing the work
and this is where the state gets to
stand up and do the same
thank you
so you know other questions thank you
also signed up to speak is Suzanne
tansky
um representing herself in Dartmouth
health
good
afternoon
thank you guys for being here and
sticking through this tummy grumbling as
well uh chairman McDonald and members of
the committee thank you very much for
the opportunity to speak in strong
support of SB 263 which will permanently
extend the granite the New Hampshire
Granite advantaged Health Care program
my name is Dr Suzanne tansky I'm a
practicing pediatrician at Dartmouth
Health children's and I'm the Section
Chief and vice chair of General
Pediatrics and a professor at the
medical school I'm speaking today on
behalf of myself on behalf of Dartmouth
health and that of many of my position
in pediatrician colleagues I too I'm
going to put a little personal face on
this most of my patients are younger and
so they don't qualify for Medicare
Medicaid Advantage but my parents of my
kids do and I'd like to speak with one
example of taking care of many parents
who have unmet health care needs and for
many years that's been the case but I'm
going to talk about a success story I'll
talk about Julie that's not her real
name but I've known Julie for about
seven years as the pediatrician for her
kids and about a year ago we had her
come in for her uh daughter's six month
well child check we screen all of our
moms at six months for maternal
depression and she scored incredibly
high and in depression and in talking
with her she said I don't know how I can
pay for this and then she said wait a
minute I just got Health Care insurance
through Medicare Medicaid Advantage we
were able to get her the health she need
the help that she needed she was already
employed she works at a grocery store
and by getting her this incredibly
important mental health health we were
able to keep her at work keep her being
a better mom to her kids support her
family and have a better household and
better Society for herself and everyone
else so there are very personal stories
of success for this program this impacts
our kids our families our society and
our and everyone throughout New
Hampshire and I applaud you for taking
this up and for continuing this this
program and making this permanent I'd be
happy to take questions thank you
saying no questions short and sweet
foreign
good afternoon and thank you for the
privilege of speaking to you sure I have
a very short statement
um
I'm a retired physician
I live in New Market and I serve on the
board of Southeastern New Hampshire
Services those services are drug and
alcohol treatment services
so my comments will be an echo of what
you've heard
a bit
um
yeah my point of reference is Saving
Lives it's uh goes with my practice
and
Southeastern does that it's in Dover
the services it provides our outpatient
and inpatient treatment of substance use
disorders
um
it's been there doing that for 40 years
I've served on the board for 23. I do
that because this is a valid effective
organization struggling to help people
who are struggling
to get out of addiction and into
recovery
it's hard work
the reimbursement of our staff is really
inadequate and
with inflation and competing salaries
elsewhere
that's a real problem for us
90 percent of our clients
are Medicaid
50 percent of our annual revenue is
Medicaid
and as you know we're dealing with a
massive problem
last year we had 434
confirmed
overdose deaths
and a few years ago when they measured
oh someone's already said this a hundred
thousand nationally overdose deaths so
the work being done there is critical
and the support we get from Medicaid or
bdas is also critical
so I'm here to support this legislation
anything that would enhance expand
Medicaid coverage and ideally make it
permanent
um
we simply can't sustain our operations
so I urge you
to pass this legislation
and I thank you and I thank you all
for all of the work you do for all of us
all of the time
thank you
you're welcome you're taking questions
do we have any questions or
also signed up to speak is Susan Stearns
good afternoon chairman McDonald and
members of the committee for the record
my name is Susan Stearns and I'm a
resident of samberton
I'm here today in support of Senate Bill
in the interest of full disclosure I am
employed as the executive director of
Nami New Hampshire however I do not come
before you today in that role
I come before you in what I consider to
be my most important role
that of a mother
my child was first diagnosed with an
emotional disorder at age five a serious
one at age eight and a serious mental
illness at age 14.
raising my child was not an easy task
however we were lucky
my employer offered health insurance
that covered my child and he was able to
access the mental health treatment that
kept him at home in his school and not
in an emergency department or
residential placement
as my child grew up there were many
sobering realizations for me as a mother
that his path would often be different
from that of other children because of
his disability that not everyone in the
world would be as patient with him and
his approach to life
and that he might not be able to work 40
hours a week for all of his adult life
and that he might not have access to
treatment
that last one terrified me
my child had been a treatment success
story despite some difficult times he
never required a visit to an emergency
department or a hospitalization
but without treatment which he would
lose access to without insurance I Knew
Too Well what his path would likely be
he would decompensate
probably become unable to function be at
risk of hospitalization or even
homelessness
once that happened after what would
likely be a several year period he would
probably be determined to be disabled
and therefore eligible for traditional
Medicaid because his mental illness
would have proven so disabling
one in five adults and one in six
children in our state has a mental
health disorder and I am certainly not
the only mother to lose sleep many
nights fearing for her child's future
Access to Health Care
as my child approached his 26th birthday
he and I sat down to apply for Medicaid
expansion coverage for him
a few weeks later his enrollment letter
arrived
and I read it and wept
since first becoming eligible for
Medicaid expansion my child has had
periods where he has been able to work
and has had his health insurance
provided by an employer or been able to
purchase it himself on the marketplace
when times have been more challenging he
has been able to access the mental
health treatment necessary for him to
live a full life through Medicaid
expansion
so to all the legislators who enacted
Medicaid expansion in our state and
those who are working to move it forward
with this legislation to reauthorize it
thank you
words cannot express the gratitude that
this mother has for the safety net that
Medicaid expansion is provided to my
child and I know I am only one of many
parents to feel this way so thank you
for helping us all sleep a little better
at night knowing our children have
access to Essential Health Care
thank you
any questions
also signed up to speak is Christina
hello my name is Christina I am
Christina Fitzpatrick I am the state
director for AARP New Hampshire and I am
here today to speak in support of SB 263
ARP has 210 000 members in New Hampshire
and what I would like to do is explain
to you today why
um why SB 263 and the permanent
reauthorization of the program is
important for our constituents people 50
and older and specifically people 50 to
64. because people older than that most
likely qualify for Medicare
so people
um age 50 to 64 were probably not
eligible for health insurance through
Medicaid prior to the development of the
granted Advantage Healthcare program
because the program the Medicaid was
only available to people with children
people with a disability and some people
now with the Medicaid expansion the
granted Advantage Health Care Program
they are
um if they if they qualified with their
low income they may have a job with no
health insurance they may have lost a
job and have trouble getting a new one
um and that is more likely when an older
worker loses their job it's much more
difficult for them to become re-employed
and to become re-employed in a job
offering comparable pay and benefits
insurance is especially important for
people 50 and older
because we know that people without
access to to health insurance delay care
which can lead to late diagnosis poorer
outcomes more expensive treatment and
that's especially true for older people
because they are more likely to have
health care needs more likely to have
chronic health conditions that need to
be managed
and the lack of health insurance can
make it harder for them to stay in the
workforce
you have heard from others about how
this is important for how extending this
program is important because it people
when people have access to health
insurance they are healthier
they are less likely to seek
uncompensated care in hospitals that
leads to Savings in the state budgets
means lower premiums for employers and
for people with Private health insurance
we get all of this with the federal
government absorbing 90 percent of the
costs and this program brings in 500
million dollars a year to the state of
New Hampshire which helps to improve our
economy in addition to helping people
maintain their health
we know that the granite Advantage
Healthcare program has created sizable
positive effects in New Hampshire it's
time to make the program permanent I
urge you to vote in favor of Senate bill
263.
also signed up to speak is Lisa Madden
for the New Hampshire Community
periodically I do need to remind
everyone and you're all doing a great
job by the way we do have a three-minute
time limit but everybody's being great
so promise to stick to it hello everyone
my name is Lisa Madden I'm the president
and CEO of Riverbend Community Mental
Health Center in Concord I also serve as
the vice president of Behavioral Health
for Concord Hospital
I'm here today representing the New
Hampshire Community Behavioral Health
Association which is comprised of all 10
of the state's non-profit Community
Mental Health Centers all of whom
strongly support permanent authorization
of Medicaid expansion in 2023. thank you
for giving me the opportunity to speak
to you today
there's no doubt that the benefits of
granted Advantage Healthcare program for
New Hampshire residents who need mental
health care and substance abuse and
addiction treatment services are
significant
data from the division of Medicaid
services show that in 2022 over 11 000
individuals enrolled in the program
received mental health outpatient
treatment almost 30 000 use Mental
Health medication treatment and almost 9
000 receive substance use disorder
outpatient services
in collaboration with several State
departments ease of access to mental
health care and substance use disorder
Services has greatly improved the rapid
response access point simplifies the way
one can access Mental Health Services
the doorway is a network of providers
that simplifies the way one can access
opioid and other substance use disorder
treatment
improving access is a critical step but
we have access having Access to Health
Care insurance through Medicaid
expansion allows people to continue to
participate in the treatment over the
long term
please allow me to share a couple of
examples Joe lives in Laconia he was
previously uninsured homeless living in
a shelter and not engaged in treatment
thanks to the granted Advantage Program
he became a patient of the local
Community Mental Health Center in April
21. with the help of the cmhc staff Joe
was able to enroll in the bridge program
he began receiving Case Management
Services through that program
he has remained positive throughout his
recovery and now three years later has
his own apartment he's employed and
actively focusing on his budgeting
skills so he can be more independent
Bob is a young man referred to the
Concord doorway from the Concord
Hospital Emergency Department in the
spring of 22.
during his assessment he identified many
barriers to staying engaged in treatment
he was uninsured unhoused unemployed and
had a history of serious mental illness
including considerable self-harm
behaviors
Barbara eagerly completed the
application for Medicaid with the
assistance of the doorway staff the new
parameters for expanded medicaid allowed
Bob to be eligible for insurance
he was immediately successfully referred
to the residential substance use
disorder treatment program where he was
admitted for care within three days of
his arrival to the doorway
Bob continues to gain make gains in his
recovery he has completed residential
partial hospital and intensive
outpatient levels of care he has moved
into long-term recovery housing as of
last summer
the drug court is another successful
program that would not be able to
function without Medicaid expansion in
this program clients commit to engaging
in treatment for mental illness and
addictions versus being incarcerated
having access to insurance is critical
to their success in the community I was
recently told the story of one client
who had never entered treatment before
Medicaid expansion
this person this person first became
involved in the criminal justice system
in 1985. it's a good start wrapping up
okay they spent a lot of time in the
prison system but at 48 years old was
finally able to get access to care is
working full-time and went back to
school without the Medicaid Program
people like Bob and Joe would not have
access to the services they need
this program is a Lifeline for many
individuals in need of treatment and we
ask you to please support with an ought
to pass for Senate Bill 263. thank you
thank you
any questions
of Representative Shapiro thank you Mr
chairman and thank you Miss Matson for
taking my question I know that even with
Medicaid expansion that the community
mental health centers are
um struggle with funding and struggle
with hiring people big struggle with
paying competitive salaries
um I think
we all secretly are thinking well
Medicaid expansion is going to be
reauthorized
um some of the you know the length of
time
Etc is in question but I think it's
important for us to keep in mind that
about 10 states have not never passed
Medicaid expansion and so my question to
you is
what would it mean to your Center and
the other Mental Health Centers of
Medicaid expansion went away oh thank
you very much for that question it's
very important
um I think it's important to know that
we are able to serve a demographic that
we were not previously able to serve and
I think that the you would see an
increase in the utilization of emergency
departments an unfortunate increase in
overdose and other high-risk behaviors
for folks who are not able to access
treatment
the open uh the ability to access
treatment with the ease that has been
allowed with Medicaid expansion has
served thousands of people who would not
have sought care prior because it would
have no means for payment so it is of
critical it's a critical nature for our
organization to be able to serve them
and to be able to stay solvent in doing
that because we do not have the capacity
to provide the care without some type of
compensation
thank you thank you
other questions
seeing none thank you thank you very
much
also signed up to speak is Richard
good afternoon
good afternoon everybody uh thank you
for this opportunity
um my name is Richard Wiggins and uh I'm
a staff member at Nami New Hampshire I
grew up in San Martin have lived there
with my wife for the last 15 years
uh I have been in recovery from
substance misuse and childhood trauma
for the last 28 years having been able
to grow in my recovery has enabled me to
give back to many individuals as well as
the community using my lived experience
I have worked in substance use disorder
treatment a sober living community based
on the 12 steps and now at Nami New
Hampshire
as a peer support specialist in a
transitional housing service run by NFI
North right here in Concord
my knowledge of the many benefits that
Medicaid expansion of the granted
Advantage has brought to our state is a
result of one of our two adult children
children's needs he's 37 years old and
has a very diffic has had a very
difficult life starting in his early
teens up to the present his uh his
challenging challenges began with
skipping school which led to marijuana
use and eventual dropping out of Earl in
it excuse me dropping out of high school
early before graduation uh long story
short the the substance use increased to
the point of jail time multiple
treatment facilities and bouts of
homelessness
a little more than three years ago he
almost died from a drug of Overdose and
was luckily found and brought to the
hospital where he was on life support
for eight days
he is now living with a traumatic brain
injury it has been a long road to his
own version of recovery but he hasn't
had a drink or in an illegal drug for
almost three years
uh
it needs to be said that Jeremiah has
struggled with mental health issues all
along
fortunately he is living in Nashua and
works at the hearts peer support center
and has many folks around him that are
so important to his recovery
most of this success is due to the
assistance from the New Hampshire
granted Advantage Health Care Program
and I say most of that's a large part of
it uh SB 263 which reauthorizes The
crucial and successful New Hampshire
granted Advantage Health Care Program is
one of the most impactful measures the
legislate legislature can employ in
supporting Granite Staters
and I must acknowledge my wife's
contribution to my our son's recovery
because she's a social worker and is
able to go handle all the paperwork that
is involved in getting somebody into
this system
and I thank you thank you
any questions
also signed up to speak is Christina
good afternoon good afternoon
my name is Christina loder I am the
director of behavioral health and
substance use services at Harbor care
which is a non-profit federally
qualified Health Care Center in Nashua
New Hampshire I'm here today to discuss
the importance of permanently
reauthorizing the granite Advantage
Health Care Program
um as a health care center we serve over
2 600 unique patients
many of which are on Medicaid
instead of going over statistics today I
wanted to take a moment
to share a clients story that I think
highlights the importance of the granted
sure yes would you speak a little closer
to the mic please
okay sorry
um
so I would like to take a brief moment
to share a client's story that
highlights the importance of the granted
Advantage Healthcare program a client
named Michelle who came into treatment
with us through our Cynthia Day family
center which is a residential substance
use disorder treatment center for
pregnant and parenting mothers when she
arrived she was six months pregnant she
was using over five grams of fentanyl in
crystal meth each day through IV and she
had been homeless for several months she
had no prenatal care up to that point
she was able to come into treatment and
stabilize she was able to access Primary
Care through our health center as well
as Dental mental health and substance
use mat services
she had her baby while she was living in
treatment with us and was able to start
her journey as a new mom being healthy
and happy
she received care for approximately nine
months
and graduated successfully from our
program when she was graduating she
transitioned to her own apartment to
live independently
she has maintained her sobriety for
almost two years she was able to access
health care services she needed because
she was insured through the granite
Advantage Health Care Program now
Michelle and her daughter are living
happily and healthy together Michelle
said I am not surviving I am living
Michelle's story is an example of how
these benefits truly do help the people
in our communities every day
so I'm asking that you consider
permanently reauthorizing this Bill
thank you thank you
any questions
also signed up to speak of Mike Rolo and
Michelle Lawrence from the American
well that's a fancy handout
yeah
good afternoon everyone
good afternoon my name is Michelle
Lawrence and I'm from Manchester New
Hampshire today I'm here to discuss my
about 14 years ago around my 31st
birthday I was diagnosed with a rare
chronic cancer not a very fun birthday
present
at the time I was working as a case
manager for a non-profit organization in
my peers are planning weddings
purchasing their first homes having
their first kids and I was left trying
to wrap my mind around my cancer
diagnosis
I needed to learn about my diagnosis in
treatment options while figuring out how
to cover all the costs of treatment on
my own
I didn't want to leave my surviving
family with any medical debt or have to
take on the burden of financially
supporting me
I wanted to remain as independent as
possible as most adults do
and after research I learned that cancer
patients are two and a half times more
likely to file for bankruptcy after they
are diagnosed according to the Fred
Hutchinson cancer research center based
in Seattle
they say life is priceless but I beg to
differ it comes at a cost
as a single person supporting myself
financially the majority of my income
went and has gone towards medical
expenses
what I'm about to share is not a
complaint but facts because I'm grateful
for what I do have
I have done the math and over the past
13 years with co-pays deductibles and
out-of-pocket expenses I would have
owned a very nice home by now a nice car
and traveled
if I added up just the co-pays to see
the doctors and it would be about twenty
thousand dollars that's just to step in
foot in the doctor's office
over the past 13 years I have delayed
treatment skipped doctor's appointments
not followed up with recommendations and
even delayed care due to Insurance costs
at times I had to decide whether to go
to the doctor's office or pay rent
and I shared this with you today because
most people looking at me would never
know that I was facing those choices
those aren't decisions a cancer patient
or anyone should have to make
I am not living the American dream I
rented a car I rent an apartment drive a
12 year old car and with paycheck to
paycheck cancer is expensive and private
insurance is just as expensive but we
say life is priceless and our actions
need to start reflecting that
this year when my employer let me go I
could not keep up with my health care
costs and I couldn't afford cobra
while trying to meet my basic needs
applying for Medicaid was and the best
option I was so thankful I qualified
with Medicaid I've had the full access
to all the medical care I need including
Home Health Therapy medication and for
the first time in my cancer journey of
almost 14 years the primary focus has
been on my health care not my insurance
and insurance costs
and with treatment in access to care
I have regained strength and even
started a small part-time job
I'm not waking up in the middle of the
night thinking about or having to decide
to pay rent or delay treatment and be
able to seek the care I need follow up
on recommendations and not be concerned
about racking up medical debt I don't
have to worry about debt collectors or
those notices in the mail
the stress it alleviates is beyond words
it makes me emotional just thinking
about it it's why I volunteered to share
my story with all of you today
access to Quality and Affordable Health
Care impacts us all on a micro and macro
level
not only am I a healthier person because
I have the care I need and don't have to
delay any treatment I am able to
contribute to society I could start
wrapping up please yep Medicaid
expansion RSP 263 would enable the state
of New Hampshire to have healthier peers
constituents and family members it
empowers people to access printed
preventative care follow doctors
recommendations and take medications as
prescribed all of these actions have
been proven to cause patients to utilize
Emergency Services less saving everybody
from employers to you invest in Medicaid
and show us life is priceless
thank you Mr chairman just for the
record Mike Rolo American Cancer Society
government relations director inside
your packet I was going to go through
Michelle
um
really was the focus today not me I was
just here for moral support but inside
your packet you'll see a letter from me
Michelle's testimony one pager on facts
and figures of what Medicaid expansion
and cancer what means it with cancer
for cancer patients in New Hampshire and
then a storybook about the impacts of
Medicaid expansion and what it's had on
a number of different cancer patients in
our state so with that we're happy to
answer any questions you may have sure
thank you very much thank you any
thank you Mr chairman and I hope you'll
indulge me I'm just going to make a
statement that um I'm I'm very thankful
for your testimony today and I know that
you're under a great deal of stress
and I just um I'm going to be thinking
about you thank you for your time
thank you representative
thank you
very much
I'd like to also
make a statement
for you and for everybody else that has
testified today
you know telling could very personal
stories
that
keep reminding me as to why I keep
coming back here that for all of these
years it is the reassurance that I get
from individuals who may be under pain
when they're up
testifying but that it means a great
deal
to us to see so many people and I can
remember the day that we passed
that vote and I won't go into the
details of what happened but that was
remarkable in love itself that so thank
you very much from all of us I really
say these kinds of things that not that
it's been very touching today and I
think it has spent everybody else here
thank you thank you representative and
you know I not to take up too much more
time but
this program means a lot financially to
a lot of businesses into the Health Care
system as a whole
but it's much more than that and for
organizations like mine for people like
Michelle it means a lot more than the
bottom line it's their lives so we
that's why we we do the work we do and
thank you for recognizing that
representative thank you any other
questions or comments
you're seeing none okay thank you thank
also signed up to speak is Jamie powers
I don't
believe stuff
okay
oh do you want to see if she's out there
also signed up to speak is Dylan Knowles
from
um
I'm not sure the name of the company but
okay
Dylan Knowles
not sure the name of your company home
something living okay
okay
yeah you need important thank you there
we go first time no that's fine yeah
that's fine
welcome thank you in about three minutes
okay so I just just go yeah whatever you
guys say all right yeah
um so as you already know my name's
Dylan uh I run those two companies uh a
little bit about myself and why I have
uh first in experience as to the
importance of Medicaid and related
Services is uh I grew up impoverished I
was born in uh Lynn Mass and then when
we left there there's no Mass health
um I got Medicaid uh in New Hampshire as
a kid uh healthy Goods gold I think and
um I was a great student uh a student
athlete great GPA
um and then I got addicted to a
prescription opiates
and uh from there I kind of fell off a
cliff
um
and only as a result of the services
which I couldn't have afforded on my own
in my life today
um between having to go to
you know partial hospitalization or
detox or being on life support when I
overdosed not to be too graphic but uh
yeah I'd only sit before you today
because I I was provided a service that
I definitely couldn't have afforded
myself
um and now I have the uh not only honor
but a responsibility to my peers who are
going through the same thing locally and
um
they come out of detox rehab or they're
homeless and they don't have the means
to pay for their own services and um
these individuals uh over the first few
months they they're allowed you know
they're able to get the mental health
treatment they need the physical
treatment some of them come in with a
lot of conditions drug and alcohol abuse
are both devastating to the Mind into
the body
um and then after about a year some of
them
um
make really good money and they pay
really good taxes and they have their
own insurance whether it be you know
they pay themselves or through the
companies they're at and again they're
only alive and able to do this because
of that initial stepping stone so I know
this isn't speculation this isn't my
guess this is uh first in experience
that this works it works very well and
then ultimately even if it's about money
at the end of the day these individuals
myself included pay really good money
for taxes and continue to buy back into
the program otherwise we would be a
virgin on a system you know we're not
going to be turned on health care and
then we can't pay for it no one's paying
for it and uh we create a problem rather
than a solution so uh
that's that's that's my story man
thank you thank you
uh any questions
representative Weber
would you believe we all think you did a
great job of testifying and thank you
for coming and sharing yourself yeah
very good thank you it's hard to mess up
thank you man
any other questions or comments
say no thank you
also signed up to speak is Sean
cannizzaro from Hope to Freedom recovery
homes
um
okay all right I'll go to someone else
I'm not sure the last name Jonathan
Gerson
from New Hampshire Corrections uh and
into action
service living how close am I I'll let
good afternoon chair and uh members of
the committee uh my name is Jonathan
Garrison I'm a resident of Manchester
New Hampshire I'm a recovery addict uh
advocate
I'm a board member of the New Hampshire
Coalition recovery residences
and I'm the owner of seven certified
recovery homes
our home serve a total of 100 residents
serving both men and women I come to you
today representing those men and women
typically someone arrives at our
recovery house after first completing
some form of inpatient treatment first
thankfully with Medicaid expansion New
Hampshire has exponentially increased
access to inpatient treatment options
over the last five years
making it viable for providers to serve
the Medicaid population
once that individual completes their
treatment program they are then stable
and appropriate for one of our recovery
homes
when they arrive many of them are
connected to recovery support services
such as laidac and mental health
counseling medication management and
medicated assisted treatment
this allows for a continuity of care
which is incredibly critical in early
recovery
these essential Services would not be
available to them without Medicaid
expansion
many of them wouldn't have found the
doors to inpatient treatment to begin
with now fast forward several months
into their stay with us
which ranges anywhere from six six to
eighteen months they're now gainfully
employed they are stable on medications
they are beginning reunification with
their families and loved ones they're
resolving outstanding legal issues they
are becoming financially self-sustaining
they are now contributing to the
community as opposed to burdening it
a large number of them are now offered
health coverage through their employers
they no longer require Medicaid
with these examples the Medicaid system
is doing exactly what it's intended to
do
to bridge the gap to a vulnerable
population
without Medicaid expansion we have
higher rates of homelessness recidivism
overdose and relapse Medicaid expansion
is a Cornerstone of all the progress in
New Hampshire's response to the
substance use disorder epidemic I speak
for our residents when I say many
wouldn't be here without it
I urge the committee in the legislature
to permanently reauthorize Medicaid
expansion
thank you for your time
could we get a copy of your testimony
please
Mr panazero is is he present okay
welcome I hope to Freedom recovery homes
is that the mea company
yes okay
you have three minutes sir yeah thank
you
we can go ahead okay hi everyone my name
is Sean kanazaro I am co-owner of hopes
of Freedom recovery homes and uh I'm
making Lansing my folks I have a couple
bullet points that I want to touch on
and
not the most professional speaker I just
speak from the heart and that's what
really hits the people when I share my
story my experience
you know the thing is
from heroin addiction alcoholism crime
like I have totally ruined my entire
life I have it back now I got it back
now I've done almost 17 years in prison
I've been in and out of treatment
centers in Massachusetts and in Mass I
had to use State Insurance
up here uh when I moved to New Hampshire
I had suffered an air fatal overdose and
ended up in a sober living a recovery
home in Littleton New Hampshire
and when I went there one of the
requirements was I had to get a
therapist and I I couldn't get it
because I still had Massachusetts
insurance so New Hampshire wouldn't give
me Insurance until that was canceled and
I get it uh and it just took a while so
you know thank God for Littleton
Regional hospital they paid for me to
see a therapist for over a year
and I was employed I ended up getting a
job up there and then my employee
offered me insurance so I took that for
a little bit but what I was noted and I
became the manager of that recovery
house and what I noticed was
guys coming out of treatment centers
that had to live in these sort of living
houses that had to follow rules but they
couldn't because they couldn't get a
therapist because they couldn't get
insurance
now these guys don't have jobs they
they're barely you know uh cognitive
they they don't know you know some of
them didn't even know how to make a bet
you know um
and the problem was I seen people leave
because when an addict or an alcoholic
feels like they can't do something
um
it it puts a toll on on on on the way we
think and the way we feel about each
other ourselves so people were leaving
and relapsing and dying because they
couldn't follow the rules and when
someone gets clean that's all we want to
do we just want to follow the rules and
do the right thing
um to speed it up
you know I would get phone calls to try
to help people get into detox and every
time I would call these detox facilities
the first thing they would ask is do
they have insurance
and a lot of these guys that I was
trying to help they didn't have
insurance so what happens is now they
continue to use they continue to get
high and we all know what happens now
now they continue to die
basically if if this doesn't if this
doesn't get permanently
reauthorized like people are gonna die
you know um
I had a good friend of mine
on a waiting list he was waiting to get
insurance and he relapsed and got high
one last time and he's dead
you know that was a really good friend
of mine whose struggled his entire life
uh with drug addiction alcoholism and
you know to speed it up a little bit
more if you could start wrapping up
please okay yes uh to speed it up a
little bit more I own a recovery house
uh sober living like the one I got
cleaning and part of the requirement is
you have to get insurance and you have
to get a therapist because a therapist
is very important for someone like
myself to unpack all the trauma and
stuff that we've been through and we
also allow folks that are on mat
medicated assistant treatment and I
think every guy in my house that's on
mat Medicaid is paying for so if they
don't have their Medicaid they're going
to be dope sick for a lack of better
words and what happens when we're Dope
Sick we go out we commit crime we rob
banks we rob stores we steal from our
loved ones we get high or we die
so it's either we get insurance or we
can just buy body bags because that's
what's going to happen people are going
to die so I urge you strongly or
encourage you to strongly reauthorize
this permanently and thank you for your
also signed up to speak is Alyssa Nye
foreign
honorable chair members of the committee
my name is Alyssa Eng and I am the
coordinator for Merrimack County Drug
Court
I'm in support of continuing Medicaid
expansion and SB 263 I'm employed by
Riverbend Merrimack County's Community
Mental Health provider so I am also so I
also have a front row seat to the
benefits of Medicaid expansion
insurance is another huge deterrent and
roadblock for our participants can I
interrupt can you move the microphone
closer to you please we're having a
little trouble hearing thank you
better okay
insurance is another huge deterrent and
roadblock for our participants who
struggle with substance use disorder
Medicaid expansion has allowed them to
receive medicated assisted treatment MIT
higher levels of substance use treatment
like residential and partial
hospitalization programs psychotropic
medications and the ability to focus on
the recovery and reintegration to the
into the community instead of
astronomical medical bills the vast
majority of our participants rely on
Medicaid expansion for the substance use
treatment and overall health care
the stability that Medicaid expansion
has provided allows individuals to
address their substance use disorder
which allows them to find employment
that
provides proper benefits along with the
paycheck they need to become independent
I wanted to share with you a few
specific stories I've seen throughout my
time with drug court in Riverbend one
participant who has spent years in
active addiction causing permanent
issues with his teeth has been able to
have 10 teeth pulled while on a mare
health and has fully fitted with posts
and partial dentures his mental health
and self-confidence has entirely changed
since his procedure until this month
Mari Health was the only Medicaid plan
to offer dental coverage I've also seen
many participants go from relying on
Suboxone a daily medication to fight
cravings and physical withdrawals to
supplicate a monthly injection that
provides the same effects supplicate is
a thousand dollars in injection
but it has decreased medication misuse
and allows for a slow taper off
medication altogether
lastly a client with persistent mental
illness who is living in a rental rented
storage unit was able to stabilize on
the correct medications move into an
apartment find full-time employment and
graduate our program
Medicaid expansion hasn't just helped
individuals like these it is played an
essential role in building New
Hampshire's overall substance use
treatment system
when I started working for drug court
obtaining a residential treatment bed
for a participant who's actively using
substances who's upwards of three weeks
since Medicaid expansion residential
facilities have opened their doors or
expanded Services as they are able to
remain open due to program fees being
paid by State insurance companies
it now can take less than 24 hours for
acceptance
saving time and Drug Court resources the
drug court team is housed within the
choices program of Riverbend we share a
space with their treatment program
choices is a voluntary substance use
program the number of intakes and
services rendered have increased
substantial substantially since Medicaid
expansion without insurance as a barrier
people are voluntarily seeking treatment
and changing their lives and their
families lives people voluntarily
seeking treatment and building their
recovery skills or not making it to my
office door with multiple felonies
following them decreasing Correctional
Facilities spending drug court Grant
spending court and policing expenses
the drug crisis in New Hampshire I mean
never be fully eradicated but we can
continue to do everything we can to
combat it and reduce the amount of
Overdose deaths
this state sees every year
463 over to overdose deaths in New
Hampshire last year it's terrifying to
think what these numbers would look like
and how many lives would be lost without
Medicaid expansion there to support
individuals and Families in Need and
support our overall treatment system I
want to thank you all for your time and
your consideration and permanently
reauthorizing Medicaid expansion
thank you
representative Weber has a question
thank you so much for taking my question
uh
I hadn't thought about this aspect of it
before but would you say from your
experience that this not only has
benefits to the individual benefits to
Health Care overall but is also a crime
reduction measure absolutely
[Music]
um
providing treatment and having that
available for our participants
we see less recidivism
um we do like a risk assessment which is
the risk to reoffend um to be in drug
court you have to be high risk on that
assessment
um when I've been
redoing them before my participants
graduate they go from high risk to low
um it's there the numbers with the
treatment that we're able to provide
thank you very much and thank you for
the work you do thank you other
questions
also signed up to speak is Keith Howard
Mr Howard here
also signed up to speak is David Jarrett
thank you Mr chair members of the
committee for the record my name is Dave
duvet I'm a senior vice president for
public policy for the business and
industry Association I'm here to convey
the strong support for New Hampshire's
private sector employer Community for
this bill it's been a long hearing a
fruitful hearing so I'll keep my
testimony short I have provided written
testimony when you receive the written
testimony you'll notice at the bottom
bia's Mission which is promoting a
healthy climate for job creation and a
strong New Hampshire economy
it's hard for me to think of any other
bill this session aside from perhaps the
state budget that has more of an impact
on job growth and a healthy New
Hampshire economy
but it could easily go the other way if
this program
is not is not
renewed at the end of the year
we've heard a lot from the provider
community and a lot from individuals
explaining how important expanded
medicaid is to them it is equally
important to New Hampshire's employer
community
if this program goes away
means at the very least a billion
dollars every biennium will not be
coming into the state from the federal
government obviously that will have an
economic impact hospitals will feel it
directly but hospitals
sound like a cold entity hospitals are
really made up of individuals employees
whose job is to provide care to all of
us
all of those individuals will feel the
impact of that loss of Federal Aid to
support this program which means that
their spending will be impacted they're
spending for food they're spending for
rent they're spending for a mortgage
they're spending for schools cars any
commodity will be impacted the ripple
effect of losing that money will spread
throughout New Hampshire's economy but
I'd also like to focus on why this is
important for employers especially
employers who provide a health care
benefit and even more especially for the
small business employers who struggle to
provide a health care benefit if we lose
that revenue from the federal government
which supports this program we'll go
back to the battle days of 10 years or
more where hospitals had to pass on the
cost for uncompensated care to other
buyers of health insurance which in New
Hampshire is primarily employers what
that means is employers especially the
small business Community
it will make it even more difficult for
them to provide a health care benefit so
I would suggest if this program is
allowed to Sunset it's not only the
people on the program who will lose
access to health care insurance and and
health care services it's many employers
especially of the small business
community that will also lose their
health care about it happy to answer any
questions thank you representative
Shapiro
thank you Mr chairman and thank you Mr
jubay for taking this question I wonder
since you're talking about
the effects on Medical Care obviously
and on individuals but also on
businesses on employers on the economy
and all the cascading effects on the
other parts of the economy can you speak
a little bit about what the advantages
or disadvantages would be of
um
reauthorizing the program for two years
versus making it permanent
well we support permanent
reauthorization I want to make that
clear one of the issues about just
providing a two-year reauthorization I
mean is a practical reason there's no
reason to do so this is not a new
program we have 10 years experience and
10 years of documented data showing how
effective it is so it doesn't make any
sense to only reauthorize it for two
years and then have to come back two
years later and reauthorize it again
other people testifying have spoken to
the safeguards that are in the program
so is a practical level I don't believe
that that's necessary or helpful it also
I believe would impact in a negative way
competition in the state right now for
for
those entities that provide
Medicare coverage
it would be helpful for them to know
that there is a permanency to this
program by just having a two-year
guarantee you are acting as a
disincentive for other mcos to enter
this market so I would argue if you
really want to increase competition and
have a positive impact on health care
costs this should be a permanent
any other questions okay thank you thank
also signed up to speak is Dr John hink
from the New Hampshire Psychiatric
Society
talk to you Vindicated five minutes I'd
appreciate if you keep it to three yes I
think it'll be less uh good afternoon my
name is Dr Chuck hink and I'm the
president of the New Hampshire
Psychiatric Society
the New Hampshire Psychiatric Society
strongly supports SP 263 because we
believe it will improve access to mental
health care
and substance use disorder treatment in
our state better access to mental health
care and substance use disorder
treatment is really the best way to
address the Mental Health crisis in our
state as well as the opioid epidemic
suicide is the ninth leading cause of
death in New Hampshire according to the
most recent statistics from the Center
for Disease Control
and better treatment of underlying
psychiatric disorders can reduce the
risk of suicide as you know there is a
mental health crisis in our state where
citizens often must wait days or weeks
in the emergency department to access
mental health care that they need it is
much better care and more cost effective
to enable citizens to get Outpatient
Care
covered by Medicaid at an earlier stage
in their illness where they can be more
successfully treated and avoid the need
to be admitted to an emergency
department or Hospital
SB 263 may also help to address the
opioid epidemic in our state by helping
citizens to get treatment for opioid use
disorder more easily which can help
prevent tragic deaths from overdose
in closing the New Hampshire Psychiatric
Society strongly supports SB 263 as a
great way to improve access to mental
health care and substance use disorder
treatment to better address the Mental
Health crisis and opioid epidemic in our
state
please support SB 263 thank you
thank you any representative Weber
thank you if you know do you know the
number of practicing psychiatrists in
New Hampshire at this point
I would say
500 okay thank you
also signed up to speak is Dr Andrew
Laurer
from the American Cancer Society and
also representing himself
good afternoon good afternoon Mr chair
and committee members thank you for the
opportunity to testify today my name is
Andrew Lair I am a citizen I'm a
resident of lyme New Hampshire I'm a
general surgeon a surgical oncologist
and a health services researcher at
Dartmouth
um I've had an opportunity over the last
15 years to work in states that have not
expanded medicaid states that have
expanded medicaid
um
additionally I'm uh over the past 10
years I've studied Medicaid expansion
and it's impact particularly on on
common and costly surgical conditions
and Cancer Care
it's in this capacity that I think I can
provide my strong support for SB 263 in
order to do the same I moved to New
Hampshire about five years ago and found
the independent
um
strong and resilient nature of granite
stages both to be inspiring and
frustrating at times when I'm trying to
get them to follow post-operative orders
but even with this resiliency in the
strong communities that Define New
Hampshire the complexity and costs of
Health Care in the United States are too
much I've seen what happens in Prior
States when we don't have Medicaid
expansion Roy a 64 year old gentleman
who wasted away lost 30 pounds
increasing abdominal pain waiting to get
Medicare before his family found him
down in the bathroom in septic shock
with a tumor that had eroded through his
colon
uh Tanya 52 year old woman mother of two
working mother of two
um who I first saw to put up permanent
catheter and get chemotherapy seven
months after Her diagnosis she couldn't
afford her insurance and subsequently
she had to spend her time finding a job
well feeling the cancer grow in her
breast
I think about another gentleman We
performed a life-saving liver surgery on
um and on the day of discharge I went in
to talk to him and he was crying and I
said you know everything had gone great
from surgery he said I'm grateful for
all that you've done but my family had
to sell the farm that's been in our
family for four generations in order to
pay for this
now these aren't only anecdotes both in
Massachusetts and in States across the
country we know that expansion is
associated with patients presenting with
earlier disease that includes earlier
stage cancer that's more treatable and
results in longer survival with those my
preliminary evaluation in New Hampshire
as a matter of fact which I'd be happy
to follow up with you all shows that
after New Hampshire's Medicaid expansion
similarly there's reductions in the
stage at which cancer was diagnosed in
New Hampshire this corresponds to
additional likelihood of getting
treatment and improved survival
beyond the patients that it impacts I
also want to recognize the stability and
well-being that Medicaid expansion has
on our surgical Workforce we've talked a
little bit about the role that Medicaid
expansion plays in hospital stabilities
prior research shows that they there's a
significant increase particularly in
rural Hospital closures in states that
have not expanded Medicaid and so this
isn't a hypothetical Factor we know from
across the state that without this
Medicaid coverage and what the pressures
that are going on in healthcare right
now
rural hospitals in particular are facing
that stress
finally I want to talk about the moral
injury that
um has led to a significant Workforce
shortage if you could start wrapping up
I I'd be happy to
um not only from taking care of patients
that lack insurance but being told that
we can't kicking out patients before we
can take care of them because they don't
have insurance that puts a significant
moral uh injury on per individuals that
leads them to quit the job or seek care
elsewhere this is an abstract we're
recruiting a surgeon up to Dartmouth
right now who's who when I told her
about this hearing said well maybe I'll
wait to hear what happens this is a very
tangible thing for the lives and
livelihood of our of granite Staters as
well as the well-being of our Surgical
and Healthcare Workforce I urge you to
support 263. thank you
any questions
yes representative Murphy thank you very
much and thank you for taking my
question um I'm just following up one of
your comments have you
and maybe a misinterpreted what you said
but have you ever been told that you
should not or could not take care of a
patient because of their insurance
coverage
yes not in New Hampshire oh okay that's
not in New Hampshire in New Hampshire I
have not not for granted health I'm not
for any of the marketplace plans uh and
not for the few uninsured that do happen
to come in I just want to be clear but
during your time at DH you have not been
told that you cannot take care of a
patient because of insurance coverage
that is correct thank you all of those
examples were in Prior States or prior
to Medicaid expansion
thank you other questions
also signed up to speak is Keith cooning
I'm not sure how well I did with your
last name I apologize if I didn't do it
well so
close enough Mr chair hi
um Mr chair members of the committee my
name is Keith kinning I'm the advocacy
director at Waypoint
um we sit here in strong support of SB
263.
um I want to give a little bit different
perspective on this
um the way we approach families these
days is we've learned not to approach it
as a child issue or a parent issue we
approach things as the whole the family
needs help as a whole we've done this
now through voluntary services in a lot
of different ways and we see SB 263 is a
part of that so if you think about it
this way a healthy parent is a providing
parent and a healthy parent is a caring
caregiver also if they're healthy they
can do the things they need to do and we
also know
that Medicaid expansion is critical more
than just adults but is crucial to the
health and well-being of the children so
it's not just the parents that benefit
the children benefit how do they benefit
in New Hampshire more children gain
coverage in the first five years
following the adoption of Medicaid
expansion this is consistent with
research done in other Medicaid
expansion States showing that when
parents gain coverage they are more
likely to enroll their children in
coverage and to take their children to
the doctor this has in turn demonstrated
an increase in well-child visits for
children in Medicaid expansion States so
when the parent gets the health care
they're more likely to take care of
their child in the Health Care system so
they're able to go off and provide and
when the child gets otitis media they're
able to put their child into the medical
system and make sure that that child
immediately gets care and they don't
hold the parent back from going off to
the job that they need to go off to in
order to provide for the family so we
see SB 63 and Medicaid reauthorization
as beneficial to the entire family
um we think it keep keeps the families
together and keeps them out of
homelessness in other situations that
they can find themselves in if they
don't have the health care and they
can't get to their their their work so
um for this reason that we support SB
263 representative Shapiro was kind
enough to grab some of my testimony I
handed around early and it should you
should have it it looks like this it has
all the footnotes about our basic
research on this issue and I'm happy to
take any questions thank you any
questions
I have no one else signed up to speak on
Senate Bill 263 does anyone else wish to
speak on Senate bill 263.
seeing no one I am going to close the
public hearing on Senate bill 263.
that is all of the uh the title of the
legislation we had scheduled for
hearings today
so we're going to stand adjourned until
next Wednesday at which time we will
have additional hearings